Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Was ist Max FPS Reap eigentlich für eine Timeline?
Du meinst den Discord? Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Das will ich gar nicht so genau wissen, was da abgeht.
Willst du gar nicht so genau wissen.
Ich hoffe unser Discord Invite-Link
ist mittlerweile nicht mehr auf dem Reap-Channel.
Das ist echt krass, ey.
Ey, es ist die Eingangshalle zum Glück.
Das wird nämlich die Leute echt verstören.
Und Casino-Content, ja.
Ich muss das machen wie iLoveCookies.
Was hältst du von Reverse-Engineering?
Hast du dich schon mal damit beschäftigt?
Ein bisschen Reverse-Engineering werden wir heute
wahrscheinlich die Hermos versandt, Api.
Wobei das Enginieren da recht überschaubar ausfällt.
Aber erstmal basteln wir
noch einen Tracker für die DPD-Api.
Also richtig,
für alle mit BigBrain heute.
Achso, ich muss mal ein Chat-Tool
noch starten, fällt mir gerade auf.
Sonst übersehe ich mir da alle Fragen.
Richtig pega hier.
Zack.
Jawoll, starten.
Dass das Video noch jemand kennt.
Max, auch wenn jetzt ziemlich
random, es gibt eine Chance, dass
jemals wieder ein Video wie WarsterSkiller kommt.
War WarsterSkiller, wo ich...
Was war WarsterSkiller nochmal?
Das ist schon lange her, oder?
Ach das da!
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
War das das Video, meinste?
Ja, das macht man heutzutage, wenn man ein Video startet.
Ich bevorzuge...
Frag Montages.
Oh Gott, das ist so cringe, das kann ich mir gerade mal angucken.
Keine Ahnung, da muss es mal
ein gutes Game geben,
wo das irgendwie so eine Szene drin ist, die dazu passt.
Was ich viel besser fand,
ist das Video hier, das habe ich ja gelöscht.
Aber das gibt es noch auf YouTube.
Was da? Kennt ihr das da?
Das war für CoD 2015.
Wenn man seine eigenen Witze lustig findet.
Ich kann mir den Scheiß...
Das ist so ein Video, das könnte ich mir
echt zwei Stunden angucken.
Dabei, ne?
Dabei habe ich mir den Mist ausgedacht.
Und das lustige ist,
das ist 2015, ne?
Das ist 2015.
Das könntest du original für jedes weitere CoD
für jedes weitere CoD,
was danach gekommen ist, kannst du das gleiche verwenden.
Ich habe das gelöscht, weil das eigentlich aus dem
spanischen Fernsehsender ist.
Und das nicht frei zum Verwenden
zur Verfügung gestellt wurde.
Das war das Snoop Dogg, das Snoop Dogg Wolfpack.
PC-Spieler.
Ernsthaft.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal ein Witz.
Die PC-Version ist einfach
chronisch gewesen die letzten Jahre.
Jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
Ich habe mich persönlich drauf geklappert.
Das stimmt.
Das ist immer noch so.
Das stimmt, das ist immer noch so.
Terraria spielen mehr Leute als fast alle Call of Duty auf dem PC zusammen.
Weißt du, worüber die im Original reden? Ja, weiß ich.
Dedicated Server.
So dumm, ey.
Im Original reden die darüber, dass der irgendwelche Pfannen im Meer verloren hat oder so.
Im Original erzählt er dem, dass er irgendwelche Pfannen an den Strand gestellt hat und die wurden dann im Meer weggespült.
Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Also eigentlich nur halb so lustig, wie diese ganzen Fake-Interviews, die es gibt.
Das ist so ein bisschen...
Ja, deswegen kriegt er sich nicht mal so ein. Das ist halt ein Video, was im Prinzip nur lustig ist, wenn du kein Spanisch kannst.
Wenn du Spanisch kannst, ist es halt nicht lustig.
Das ist genauso, wie es online ja zig, kennt ihr ja bestimmt, so 30.000 Videos Hitler Reacts gibt.
Wo sie alle irgendwie so eine Szene aus der Untergang genommen haben.
Der Angriff Steiner ist nicht erfolgt, blablabla. Kennt ihr, hat jeder schon Videos von gesehen.
Das Problem ist, dass wir die ganzen Videos von Hitler Reacts haben.
Kennt ihr, hat jeder schon Videos von gesehen. Das Problem ist, dass wir das halt als Deutsche verstehen.
Und das ist halt, wenn du Deutsch verstehst, nicht lustig.
Aber die Amis püsten sich da drauf weg.
Die haben, da gibt es Hitler Reacts, zu jedem Vorfall gibt es ein Hitlers Reacts Video.
Genau, das ist für Deutsche halt nicht lustig.
Genau, das ist für Spanier nicht lustig.
Weil man es halt versteht.
Aber die Amis, also generell, alle anderen püsten sich da übelst drauf weg.
Weil sie halt kein Deutsch verstehen.
Wo ist jetzt die Musik hin? Achso, die habe ich ausgemacht. Aha, Big Brain.
Wenn man Musik ausmacht, geht es auch nicht.
Nee, eher das da passt eher. Hätte das gedacht.
Ja, genau, genau, genau, so was, Clocks HD.
So, ich will erstmal mein Chat-Tool starten, dass ich Fragen im Chat mitklicke.
Ich habe hier wieder zig Dinge übersehen.
Hier ist nämlich ganz ein Chat, ist rot.
Hier ist eines der Bot.
Wie viele Subs hast du mittlerweile?
Ruhig mal gucken, ich habe es gerade nicht auf.
Zumindest, ihr habt jetzt die einmalige Chance, unter die ersten 200 Subs noch zu kommen.
Und das geht ganz einfach, ganz ohne Geld auszugeben, indem man einfach seinen Twitch-Account mit seinem Twitch Prime-Account,
nein, seinen Twitch-Account mit seinem Amazon Prime-Account verknüpft.
Das ist das ganze nix.
Man kann einmal im Monat einen Streamer unterstützen, seiner Wahl, mit einem Tier-One-Sub.
Und da gibt es auch schon den ersten Sub von Asdea Aster.
Wahrscheinlich eher Asdea0815.
Pog.
Studenten können nicht mit Twitch Prime abonnieren, warum?
Echt nicht?
Warum nicht?
Geht das mit dem Amazon Studenten-Account?
Das ist ja Massive.
Pog.
Ach, meine IP hat sich geändert.
Einfach mal so, einfach so.
Einfach weil sie keinen Bock hat.
Pog.
So, ich habe oben irgendwas überlesen.
Hat es einen Grund, dass du vorhin auch nicht VirtualBox Hyper-V verwendest?
Na gut, Hyper-V verwende ich nicht, weil ich mir gar nicht mal sicher bin, ob das überhaupt dabei ist,
bei einem normalen Windows 10.
Und dazu kommt, dass Hyper-V generell nicht so der Wahnsinn ist für Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Also sprich, dass du halt eine grafische Ausgabe hast.
Den konnte beispielsweise ein paar Versionen lang und nicht mal USB-Sachen durchreichen.
Das ist Mist.
VirtualBox kann man verwenden, nimmt sich nicht viel mit VMWare.
Ich finde VMWare an sich eigentlich einfach runter.
Und das Support von VirtualBox ist ja auch ein bisschen langsam geworden.
Das ist ja schon seit ein paar Jahren bei Oracle.
Und da tut sich nicht allzu viel.
Wir können mal gucken, ob es eine Visionshistorie von gibt.
Also da tut sich nicht so viel wie bei VMWare Workstation.
VMWare Workstation ist ein rundes Produkt.
Das ist eines der wenigen Stücke Software auf dem Desktop,
wo ich wirklich auch Geld für ausgegeben habe.
Beziehungsweise auch ausgegeben würde immer noch.
Das ist auch gar nicht so teuer.
Die haben immer irgendwelche Aktionen.
Wenn du entweder einen alten Key hast,
oder die haben auch ab und zu einmal im Jahr,
oder so ist es besonders billig.
Ja, ja, bla, bla, bla.
Ja, seems legit.
Also ich würde da niemals 250 Euro für ausgeben.
Das kriegst du auch für deutlich weniger.
Keine Ahnung, bei dem Preis würde ich es wahrscheinlich
sogar mal so einen komischen Key Seller ausprobieren.
Viel wichtiger, warum kein Docker?
In Bezug auf was?
Abonniert Twitch Prime, POG, Chico SS.
Man sollte es wahrscheinlich eher Chico SS aussprechen,
weil das in Deutschland ja ein bisschen negativ behaftet ist,
die Aussprache.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Chico sind.
Meine Katze heißt auch Chico.
Also ich hab sie zwar, hier heißt sie zwar Chica auf dem Bild,
allerdings in Wirklichkeit heißt sie Chico,
weil das ehemalige Herrchen sich gedacht hat,
Chico ist ein guter Mädchenname.
Warum auch immer?
Weil, keine Ahnung warum.
Aber was haben wir hier? Twitch Prime Subscriber?
Ja, ich weiß, dass Chico Jungo erst mal ein Mädchen Spanisch,
wobei ich hab sie mit K geschrieben.
Ich glaub, man schreibt sie mit C, ja.
Und ich nenne sie manchmal Chica oder Chico.
Also offiziell heißt sie wie gesagt Chico,
aber das ist ein ziemlich beknackter Bezeichnung für eine Katze.
Deswegen wechsle ich das ab.
Das ist aber egal, weil,
wenn die irgendwas mit Chica Chico hört,
dann ist sie eh schon am Start.
Weil sie denkt, es gibt was.
Wenn sie denkt, dass es was gibt,
dann ist sie sofort am Start.
MonkaG? Was gibt MonkaG?
MonkaG ist wichtig.
Ich such mal im anderen Bildschirm MonkaG.
Ist das eine goldene Mülltonne?
MonkaG ist eine goldene Mülltonne.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das gemeint ist, oder?
Hast du im Discord gepostet?
Kann ich da jetzt reingucken?
Der ist nix, Discord ist nix.
Ach, PepoG.
Ach der, ja.
Das kann man tatsächlich machen.
Ach der mit der Brille, ja.
Dann auch gibt es Transparenz.
Okay, dann mach ich das jetzt,
wenn ihr den unbedingt braucht.
Stell ich mir mal ein.
PepoG heißt das Ding, okay.
PepoG.
Ja, Dark.
Add to Channel.
Dark ist drin, easy.
Ist geadded.
Falls du bei der Twitch-TV verwendest,
dann dauert das ein Tag, bis es gecheckt hat irgendwie.
Um was geht es heute?
Ja, das habe ich noch gar nicht erzählt.
Wir waren gerade mit allen möglichen Dingern beschäftigt.
Ja, um was geht es heute?
Übrigens, ich muss gerade nochmal was anderes erzählen.
Heute auf Twitter, ich habe heute
den ultimativen Lifehack gefunden,
für alle Leute, die nasse Schuhe haben
eine Server-Rack in der Nähe.
Nehmt einfach eine Kiste,
dass eure Schuhe auf der Höhe vom Server sind,
und dann stellt eure Schuhe dahinter,
und dann sind die Schuhe nach 2 Stunden wieder trocken.
Dazu kann man eigentlich nur sagen,
Massive Big Brain.
Oder eigentlich schon 900 IQ.
Das ist nicht übel.
Hat funktioniert, war komplett trocken danach.
Jetzt habe ich 4 Stunden anpusten lassen von den Kisten.
Das Problem ist, das ist ein bisschen widersprüchlich,
weil drumherum ist halt Klimaanlage
und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 18 Grad oder so in dem Raum.
Das ist nicht groß, was ist das?
42 oder so.
Das sieht bloß so groß aus wegen dem Karton,
weil man halt keinen Vergleich hat.
Und drumherum ist halt kalt,
aber das kommt halt das Warme vom Lüfter hinten dran,
und zack, 4 Stunden später war das Ding wieder trocken.
Da geht eh keiner rein.
Wenn da Leute reingegangen sind, haben die sich vielleicht gewundert,
warum da so komische Luft auf einmal drin ist.
Der 42 ist nicht groß.
Kommt auch immer ganz anscheinend auf die Größe an.
Also, umso größer du bist,
umso größer sind in der Regel auch die Füße.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich glaube es ist 43,5.
Ich glaube 43,5 ist es.
Ich merke mir das immer nicht,
weil ich gucke einfach in meine Amazon-Bestellung,
was ich zuletzt bestellt habe.
176,46 ist nicht schlecht, also ich bin es 174.
Ich habe früher auch immer zu große Schuhe angezogen.
Bis ich dann irgendwann gemerkt habe,
okay, so langsam war es sicher,
meine Füße wachsen nicht mehr.
Und es ist viel bequemer, wenn man Schuhe hat,
die genau passen.
Ja, also was machen wir heute?
Zwei Sachen.
Als erstes, oder ich weiß nicht,
was wir als erstes machen,
müssen wir mal schauen.
Wir müssen ja in unser,
in das Paket-Tracking-Tool müssen wir ja noch,
aktuell ist ja nur ein DHL eingebaut,
also in den Versand-Tracksor.
Ich zeige den mal für alle,
die ihn noch nicht kennen,
die ihn noch nicht gesehen haben,
was der Versand-Tracksor so macht.
Der heißt tatsächlich so.
Und zwar, was der Versand-Tracksor macht,
ist, wer hätte das gedacht, Versand-Tracksor.
Zum Beispiel kann man da automatisch
aus seinem E-Mail-Postfach
Tracking-Nummer hinzufügen lassen.
Der scannt das E-Mail-Postfach nach Tracking-Nummern
und fängt die dann an zu tracken
und kann einem eine Benachrichtigung schicken,
wenn das Ding unterwegs ist.
Aktuell kann das nur DHL,
wie man hier gerade sieht.
Dafür kann es DHL eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Das erkennt DHL,
dass das Ding unterwegs ist,
dass das Ding im Auto ist und dass das Ding angekommen ist.
Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch.
Man kann auch manuell hinzufügen eine Tracking-Nummer.
Aber die Idee dahinter ist eben,
dass man automatisch scannen lässt,
ob man Benachrichtigungen kriegt,
wo Tracking-Nummern drinstehen
und der die dann weiter verfolgt
und einen benachrichtigt,
sobald es was gibt.
Beziehungsweise, dass man das auch einfach
mit seiner Heimautomatisierung integrieren kann.
Einfach, dass man eine einheitliche Schnittstelle hat,
wo man Benachrichtigungs-Sachen zu Paketen bekommen kann
und wo man auch ordentlich AP hat, um das Ganze anzusprechen.
Aktuell ist geplant, dass wir Amazon, Logistics,
DPD, Hermes, DHL und UPS unterstützen.
Und aktuell kann das Ding allerdings plus DHL.
Das ist nicht so viel,
aber wie gesagt, DHL funktioniert schon ganz gut.
Und was wir heute machen ist,
wir gucken uns mal an,
wie das mit Hermes funktioniert.
Hermes habe ich schon gesehen.
Hermes ist ein bisschen eklig.
Hermes hat keine offizielle AP.
Das Einzige, was ich gefunden habe,
ist Hermes AP UK.
Das da.
Aber da kriegt man nichts gescheit von abgefragt.
Das ist anscheinend nur zum Erstellen von Paketen.
Das sagt ein bisschen.
Und das ist auch keine offizielle AP.
Das ist irgendwas, was man über Google findet.
Also vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll zu verwenden.
Genau.
Das heißt, wir müssen mal irgendwie gucken,
wie man...
Ach ja, übrigens danke schön noch mal
an alle, die mir Paketcodes geschickt haben.
Ohne die Paketcodes
könnte ich das hier im Stream gar nicht machen.
Zum Beispiel machen wir Sendeverfolgung Hermes.
Dann nehmen wir jetzt mal eine Nummer,
die mir jemand geschickt hat,
hier aus dem Stream, geben das ein.
Und dann sehen wir, das Ding ist unterwegs.
Und ich habe halt keinen Bock,
Webseiten zu parsen.
Das sagt, das müssen wir schon für Amazon machen.
Bei Amazon bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig,
wie Webseiten parsen.
Ähm...
Sub-Icon.
Ach, stimmt nicht, Baro.
Du warst ja noch gar nicht da.
Ja, wir haben mittlerweile ein Sub-Icon.
Einfach nicht mit Hermes senden.
Ja, das Problem ist ja...
Du hast ja Recht.
Ich würde ja auch nie im Leben mit Hermes verschicken.
Allerdings kann ich mir das oftmals
bei Online-Shops halt nicht aussuchen.
Man kann sich das ja bei Online-Shops
oftmals nicht aussuchen.
Wir haben eine Versandmethode,
das ist halt Hermes.
Und da kann man eigentlich nur dazu sagen...
Ist halt so.
So, und deswegen müssen wir uns angucken,
wie Hermes das Ganze macht.
Das können wir jetzt mal schnell machen.
Ähm...
Oh, hier, wen haben wir da?
Pinguin-Bob.
Pok.
Was?
Prime.
Pok.
Dankeschön.
Twitch-Prime-Sub.
Ist der Chat heute eigentlich...
Ist der Chat heute Cute-Chat?
Ich hab das noch sehr wenig gesehen,
dass das heute Cute-Chat ist.
Ist das Cute-Chat heute?
Oder ist das, keine Ahnung, Angry-Chat?
Hate-Speed-Chat.
Nee, das ist Cute-Chat.
Sehr schön.
So mag ich das.
Cute-Chat ist bester Chat.
Smog-Chat.
So, gefällt mir das.
Cute-Chat am Schluss.
Die Musik weiß auch nicht,
ob sie laut oder leise werden soll.
So, dann gucken wir uns das Ganze
nämlich mal an, wie Hermes das macht.
Ähm...
Und...
Boah, was geht denn hier ab?
Ach, ich hab eingestellt, dass das aussehen soll
wie ein iPhone.
Ah.
Okay, wie stellt man den Kack noch mal um?
Ach, hier, ne?
Ähm...
Und ich muss ja gestehen,
so ganz ahnungslos bin ich in dem Fall nicht,
weil ich hab mir das im Vorfall schon mal angeguckt
und es ist ziemlich einfach
von Hermes,
den Paketstatus abzufragen.
Um nicht zu sagen,
es ist...
Weil, guck mal hier,
wenn man im Network-Traffic guckt,
wo man gerade beim Punkt, weil am Anfang
einer gesagt hat hier Reverse-Engineering,
man kann sich so wirklich, so viel
reversen müssen wir an der Stelle nicht,
das ist eigentlich ziemlich easy.
Aber wenn man sich hier mal anguckt,
was das Ganze überträgt im Browser,
ja,
da wird einem irgendwann auffallen,
wenn man da so durchklickt,
da fällt einem erstmal auf irgendwie so
Empfangensendungsinformationen
Sendungsinformationen, also die sind schon mal richtig
huge, big brain, die haben den ganzen Kram
erstmal Deutsch genannt.
Teaser-Wunschzustellung,
sowas, also da weiß man schon mal, was Hermes
für ein Verein ist, Funktionsnamen, erstmal auf Deutsch machen.
Das machen
wirklich nur Next-Level-Leute.
Und Hermes ist anscheinend,
Hermes gehört anscheinend dazu.
So, und dann haben wir die einzige Funktion,
die irgendwie halbwegs sinnvoll aussieht
und sich ordentlich benannt ist,
wo darauf zu schließen ist, dass das
Leute programmiert haben, die wissen, was sie machen,
ist das hier.
Shipments.
Shipments, Services,
Tracking, Shipments. Und dann
Search nach der
Tracking-Nummer.
So,
wenn man sich das Ganze anguckt,
wenn man jetzt hier auf Response geht, sieht man,
hier hat man alles schön in
JSON drinnen, ohne dass man irgendwie HTML
parsen muss.
Navigationsleiste
CSS. Haben sie ernsthaft?
Nee, haben sie nicht, aber
das wird mir ja nicht gewundert.
Zumindest, man sieht
hier, hier ist komplett
alles drin, was wir brauchen bei Hermes.
Das ist total einfach.
Wir können uns einfach die Uhr nehmen und
das jeweilige
Hermes Tracking-Nummer
reinschreiben und schon kriegen wir alle Informationen.
Leider, leider
kriegt man bei Hermes
keine Infos drüber, in welcher Stadt das Ganze
gerade ist. So, und deswegen,
bevor wir jetzt mit Hermes anfangen,
machen wir mal was, was ein bisschen mehr Spaß macht,
weil man ein bisschen mehr Sachen machen muss, und zwar
DPD.
DPD wird lustig, weil
ich mach schonmal ein neues Projekt,
wo wir das drin ausprobieren können.
Bei welcher Konsolen-App sind wir
mittlerweile?
Konsolen-App 13, DPD,
Tracker.
DPD wird witzig, denn ich habe eine
PDF gefunden.
PDF, DPD,
API. Die machen es im Vergleich.
Ne, ne, ne, wenn man die Postlerzahl eingibt,
ich hab's ausprobiert eben mit einer Sendung von mir,
wenn man die Postlerzahl eingibt,
ist das Einzige, was bei
Hermes noch zusätzlich da
dazukommt,
Moment, wo sind wir denn?
Das Einzige, was bei Hermes noch zusätzlich dazukommt, wenn man die
Postlerzahl eingibt, ist
dass das Absende
dort vor das Paket aufgegeben
wird und die eigene Adresse drin steht.
Mehr nicht.
Also
man hat da keine Chance,
großartig raus
zu, ah gut,
bei Hermes, man kann nicht bei jedem
Service alles haben.
So, und
mit DPD wird das Ganze
ein bisschen lustiger, weil ich habe eine
PDF gefunden von DPD.
Für die DPD Cloud,
ne,
das da,
das ist anscheinend ein Service
von DPD
für Litauen und
Estland,
weil die Sprache, die es da gibt,
ist
Englisch, Litauisch,
Estländisch und
was gibt es da noch?
Estland, Litau, Lettland und
Lettländisch.
Aber, das Gute
ist, das funktioniert mit allen
DPD Paketen um ein International.
Und
Was hältst du davon, dass
Manjaro LibreOffice durch Softmaker
FreeOffice ersetzen will? Man hat es davon
abgesehen, dass ich LibreOffice für absoluten Crap
halte, aber es ist halt irgendwie
notwendig und vorhanden.
Hab ich Softmaker
FreeOffice noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ist DPD nicht
deutscher Paketdienst? Ja, kann schon sein.
Allerdings sind sie halt
huge brain und sagen
halt, die ordentliche Web API
verbieten wir bloß für Litauen an.
Kann
uns ja egal sein.
Zumindest ich habe einen PDF gefunden.
Personal Status
PDF. Und jetzt haltet euch fest,
es wird wirklich abgedreht,
was die Jungs sich von DPD
ausgedacht haben.
Und
zwar, ach ja, man sollte
davor mal was sagen. DPD hat auch eine
offizielle API. Das Problem
ist, die ist
XML Soap.
Muss man sich für registrieren mit einem API Key
und ist nervig. Allerdings
die haben auch diesen Free Service,
der wohl anscheinend für Litauen gedacht ist.
Ist aber wurscht, das funktioniert mit jeder
Paketnummer. Und
wenn man sich das PDF anguckt,
wird man nämlich erkennen,
dass die ein bisschen merkwürdige Sachen machen
bei DPD.
Das erste, was mich freut, schon mal ist,
die haben ganz gute Beispiele drinne,
wie das Ganze funktioniert. Also ich habe es
mit Curl schon mal ausprobiert.
Ah, kann man zum Beispiel sagen, hier
All Status, zack, ach so,
wir müssen eine gültige Paketnummer eingeben.
Nehmen wir eine gültige DPD
Paketnummer. Haben wir auch wieder eine
im Stream geschickt. Also hier nochmal, pock.
So, zack.
Und dann rödelt es ein bisschen
rum. Und wenn es rumgerödelt
hat, das kann manchmal 10 Sekunden
hängen oder so, aber es
kann man mitleben.
Haben wir noch nie was von Swagger Open API gehört?
Nein, haben sie nicht. Haben die wenigsten, haben davon
was gehört.
So, 3 Stunden später hat es dann aktualisiert.
Wenn man das einmal gemacht hat, geht es danach
weiter.
Huge Speed.
Ok, es ist gerade, glaube ich, überlastet.
Ich glaube, es ist gerade überlastet.
Ich habe es vorhin mit dem Curl ausprobiert, ging
ohne Probleme.
Ach hier, stimmt es doch hier.
Status Delift, das stimmt nicht.
Der Status ist zu kurz.
Normalerweise steht da noch viel mehr drinne.
Also,
als ich das vorhin ausprobiert habe,
mit der gleichen Tracking Nummer,
ob das wirklich die gleiche Tracking Nummer, ja.
Also ich habe das vorhin ausprobiert
mit der gleichen, der gleichen
Tracking Nummer, meinte ich. Ich habe noch eine
hier von DPD. Probieren wir die mal aus.
Ich habe nur eine von DPD.
Falls noch einer von euch eine Paketenummer
hat von DPD, von innerhalb
der letzten 120 Tags,
dann kann ich das mal ausprobieren.
Also, ich habe das vorhin ausprobiert,
von innerhalb der letzten 120 Tage.
Wäre das eine super Sache,
wenn er die mir zum Test zur Verfügung stellen könnte.
Man liegt
von euch nichts, außer
grob die Stadt,
wo ihr wohnt. Sonst sieht man
nichts davon, wenn man die Tracking Nummer hat.
Also ich weiß nicht,
was das hier für Schmerzen hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Als ich das vorhin ausprobiert habe,
hat es doch funktioniert.
Dann
stand da nämlich noch
in Delivery, in Root und alles mögliche.
Ah hier, der Clocks HD. Dankeschön.
Fock.
Die DPD AP ist gerade für einen Arsch.
Die ist gerade kaputt.
Ich habe es vorhin ausprobiert, da kam viel mehr raus.
Ach ja, vielleicht muss ich All-Status machen.
Kann das sein, dass ich All-Status machen muss?
Mal entscheiden.
Warum ist das PDF so schlecht?
PDF please, komm.
Ah ja, hier, gut, funktioniert.
Vielleicht geht es mit der anderen Pakete nochmal auch.
Ich denke mal, ich habe da einfach zu wenig eingegeben.
Ja, geht, jetzt geht es wieder.
Ok, alles gut.
Also was man bei DPD
aus der JSON-AP rauskriegt, ist leider
auch nicht so ganz
zufriedenstellend.
Man kriegt raus, das Ding wurde abgegeben
zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Es war unterwegs zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
es war unterwegs zu diesem Zeitpunkt, es war unterwegs zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Was interessant ist an der Stelle, man kriegt
an der DPD-AP raus,
ob es einen Fehler gibt,
also sprich, ob es die Paketnummer überhaupt gibt.
Das ist schon mal eine ganz nützliche Geschichte.
Aber es wird noch schlimmer.
Es wird noch schlimmer.
Bis jetzt ist es ja noch ok, bis jetzt sieht es ja noch ziemlich
standard aus.
So, da kann man hier
abfragen, ganz viele
verschiedenen Pakete, also mehrere Pakete
zusammen und...
Es geht alles.
Man kann auch zum Beispiel hier
noch machen
detail1, da kriegt man dann
noch so komische Servicecodes angezeigt.
Was auch immer, die uns sagen sollten.
Das Problem ist,
für mich, was mich ein bisschen nervt, ist...
In der JSON-AP
steht zwar drin, dass das Ding unterwegs ist,
es stehen aber keine genaueren Informationen
drin, wie zum Beispiel
wurde ins Fahrzeug geladen,
ist jetzt an der Station eingetroffen
und was auch nicht drin
steht, ist
der Ort.
Weil wenn man mal in der
DPD-Sendeverfolgung guckt,
wird man
feststellen,
weiter ohne
Postleitzahl, wird man feststellen,
man...
Ja, genau, man bekommt hier raus Paket
in Paket-Zustellungszentrum,
also man bekommt mehr Informationen
und man bekommt auch
ohne
die Postleitzahl
noch mehr Informationen raus, dazu muss man
aber, und jetzt wird es eklig,
dazu muss man allerdings die
CSV-AP verwenden.
Du wirst doch wissen, wo du wohnst, das ist doch nicht
meine, das ist doch nicht meine
Tracking-Nummer.
Ich würde das gerne kopieren.
Wir müssen das, wir müssen die
CSV-AP verwenden. Ich habe noch nie eine
CSV-AP gesehen.
Nein, ich möchte dich nicht stalken.
Ich brauche noch nicht mal eine Paket-Nummer
von dir, weil ich habe schon eine Paket-Nummer.
Also, man kann das jetzt ausprobieren.
Mit der Paket-Nummer geht man das an
und dann lädt er eine CSV-Datei
runter. Ich habe so eine Art von
Apionieren-Spur gesehen, ich weiß nicht, was mit dem
nirgends bei DPD los ist.
Zumindest, wenn man das öffnet,
wenn man das öffnet,
dann sieht man hier,
wir sind hier
in Transit,
in Mal,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wo Mal
liegt.
Der ZIP-Code stimmt nicht, der ist nämlich überall gleich,
obwohl die Städte unterschiedlich sind.
Ganz normale CSV-AP.
Ja, es gibt auch so viele normale
CSV-APs.
Und dann sieht man hier Freiburg, Freiburg.
Also, man erkennt, okay,
der...
Ich weiß nicht, war das vom...
War das von der Eichler?
Ich glaube, der Eichler hat die Nummer
geschickt. Ich glaube, vom Eichler
ist das die Nummer,
die wir hier probieren. Also, wahrscheinlich sehen wir
jetzt hier, dass er in Freiburg wohnt,
aber mehr erkennen wir hier im Prinzip
auch nicht.
Und...
Ja, was auch noch interessant ist,
das hier, ich habe mir vorher das
PDF ja schon angeguckt, das hier ist die
Zeit, das hier ist die
Zeit in...
Stunden,
also was in Format, ne?
In Stunden und Minuten,
allerdings
mit möglichen Leerstellen.
Also, nicht 06,
06, 09,
sondern 16,
669. So, und das hinten sind die
Minuten. Das ist
schon ein bisschen wir. So, und das
hier vorne ist auch ohne irgendwelche Trennzeichen
das...
das Datum.
7.
2.
7. Ist das auf Englisch?
Ne. Das haben die aber in ihrem
PDF drinstehen, wie rum das ist. Also, ihr seht
schon, das ist ein bisschen...
Also, schon ein bisschen hässlich,
ne?
Nein, man bekommt die Chatten, man bekommt die Stadt,
die Stadt bekommt man nicht aus der Jason-Abi. Vergiss
es. Ich habe ja schon gesagt
All und Detail1,
mehr geht nicht. Wer kann es nicht machen?
Du bekommst die Stadt nicht aus der Jason-Abi.
Das heißt, wir müssen zwei Sachen
machen. Ach ja, allerdings
teilt uns die Jason-Abi,
das ist mega-Pepega, das ist
huge-Pepega...
P...P...
D...Pepega-D ist das.
Das ist also der deutsche
Pepega-Dienst,
wenn ich mir die Api angucke. Und die ist aktuell hier,
Januar 2019.
Und...
Was soll ich jetzt sagen? Wir brauchen allerdings beide
Apis, weil
die CSV-Api,
die teilt uns
beispielsweise nicht mit,
wenn die Paketnummer nicht stimmt.
Wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel
eingebe, Paketnummer
ist Omega-Lull, ach Quatsch, Moment.
Äh...
Irgendwas mit
10 war das hinten, ne?
Wie war die
CSV-Api nochmal?
Wartet mal. Hab schon wieder
Tracking,
Copy, Tracking, so.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal was, was es garantiert nicht gibt, hier.
Omega-Lull.
Das Problem ist, man kriegt
eine CSV zurück, obwohl es die
Tracking-Nummer nicht gibt. Wenn man das öffnet,
stellt man fest,
ach Mist, okay, das funktioniert.
Ähm, ja, man kriegt eine
Fehlermeldung, wenn das nicht dem richtigen Format
entspricht, aber man kriegt keine Fehlermeldung,
wenn es die Tracking-Nummer
nicht gibt. Also nehmen wir jetzt mal eine Tracking-Nummer,
die skippt, und machen
da mal eine Tracking-Nummer draus, die es gerade nicht gibt.
Dann sieht man auch, der lädt eine CSV
runter. Ja, die könnten den 404
zurückgeben, das könnten die machen, ja.
Die könnten auch
x-beliebigen anderen Statuscodes zurückgeben,
aber, können wir
mal gucken, ob sie das tun.
Ähm, ich denke, das tun sie nicht.
Und man kriegt eine CSV zurück,
was einfach leer ist. Das heißt,
du hast eigentlich keine Ahnung so genau,
ob das stimmt. Das heißt, so wie ich mir das jetzt
überlegt hab, brauchen wir die JSON-API.
Brauchen wir die JSON-API, um
ähm,
okay.
Brauchen wir die JSON-API, um zu gucken,
ob die Paketenummer,
ob das Paket überhaupt
existiert. Du brauchst
noch eine DPD-Nummer. Kannst du mir gerne schicken, ich hab
schon ein paar, aber zum Testen sind
Nummern nie genug, ja.
Aber es hat doch eben schon noch mal eine Nummer geschickt,
muss ich mal kurz hochrollen. Ja,
top.
LogX, der StephKris,
und der Kalf, beide
DPD-Nummern geschickt, sehr schön.
Darf ich dir mal einen hier in meinem Test,
dass ich, äh,
jetzt hab ich zu viel gelöscht.
Ähm, kann man nie
genug haben,
testen. Aber das reicht, also jetzt
hab ich 5-6 Nummern.
Perfekt. Ja,
dankeschön. Das reicht zum Ausprobieren
heute. So, ähm,
und die Sache
ist die, dass wir brauchen auf jeden
Fall beide APs, um das zu verwenden.
Warum auch immer
die nichts, die liefern gar nichts.
Ach doch, guck mal hier, was liefern sie zurück?
200 liefern sie zurück.
200, auch wenn es
das Ganze nicht gibt.
Was ist das für ein Winnermann?
Das ist i3-WM.
Also man sieht, es gibt auch 200 zurück,
wenn es das Ganze gibt. Kontern-Typ,
Text-CSV hab ich
selten gesehen, dass das direkt
von einer, direkt
zurückgeliefert wird, aber ok.
Wobei Text-CSV stimmt noch.
Text-CSV ist richtig.
Ähm, was auch immer.
Es ist auch wurscht.
Ähm, zumindest
man kann an dem Status nichts erkennen.
Also die AP ist schon, wie gesagt,
deutscher PP-Gardienst.
Und...
Ja, es wird ja
noch besser.
Es wird ja noch besser. Wenn man sich jetzt mal das Dokument
von denen anschaut,
wird man feststellen, die Beschreibung
für die JSON-AP ist relativ
ok.
Allerdings, die Sprachen sind schon mal geil.
Es gibt Englisch, äh,
Estländisch,
Litauen und Lettland.
Lettländisch oder sowas.
Weil,
auch immer. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum.
Aber Hauptsache, es gibt
Englisch.
Das reicht schon mal.
Ja, steht ja auch
Estonia, Latvia,
Lithuania.
Und Portugal kann man nicht abfragen.
Ich weiß nicht,
wer das Ding designt hat. Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht
schön.
So, ähm...
Dann haben sie noch ein paar Beispiele drinne.
Das ist eigentlich ganz ok. Und was man hier
dran sieht, ist, dass man mit der JSON-AP
relativ einfach rausbekommt,
ob es einen Fehler gibt und
ähm, ob
was der Fehler ist.
Also, wir können zum Beispiel einmal
initial prüfen damit,
ob es diese Sendungsnummer überhaupt gibt.
Das würde mit
äh, das würde mit der CSV-AP schon mal nicht
richtig funktionieren.
So, ähm, dann
bla, bla, bla. Der Rest ist egal.
JSON, JSON-Output.
Kann halt ein paar Messages enthalten.
Das hier hinten ist auch schon sehr, sehr
sehr merkwürdig, ne.
Hier Nummer 1. Drop den Pickup-Point.
Hat den Status-Code
DoppKey
und Hut hat den Status-Code 02034567891014.
Allerdings, wenn man in
Pickup-Point ist, dann ist es keine
Nummer, sondern D0 Pickup
wahrscheinlich Pickup.
Man weiß es. Es ist, es ist
komplett wirr. Also, das muss man
nicht versuchen zu verstehen, was da passiert, ja.
Es ist, es ist komplett wirr.
Ähm, haben sie nochmal Beispiele
drinne, ist auch ok.
Muss man aber gar nicht so sehr
versuchen durchzublicken.
Das ist im Prinzip, kann uns im Prinzip fast
egal sein.
Kleines Side-Track.
Gib mal LibroOffice auf Ebay ein.
Ich weiß, dass LibroOffice verkauft wird.
Ich weiß ja nicht, warum man das kauft, aber ich weiß,
dass es verkauft wird.
So, ähm, und was man halt hier auch sieht, ist
man sieht keine, keinen
Progress so richtig, ne, und keine Stadt.
So, und jetzt kommen wir mal
zur CSV-AP. Die wird nämlich
noch ein Ticken eklicher als das,
was ich euch gerade schon gezeigt hab.
Immerhin, es ist ein UTF-8
CSV, ja.
Immerhin.
Ist schon mal was.
Type.
10.
Achso, das muss man angeben, dass CSV
angeben geht. Jetzt, wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr was? Sollen wir mal ausprobieren?
Also, hier kommt, hier kommt das CSV
raus.
Was passiert denn da, wenn wir da mal 9 eintragen?
Oder 11?
Nix. 12.
Ah, nix.
Ich könnte, ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn wir das
lang genug ausprobieren, finden wir irgendwelche internen
DPD-APs oder so.
Gut, ähm,
so, und dann kommt die Beschreibung von
der, von der CSV-Tabelle.
Die ist, die ist
ein bisschen, die ist ein bisschen konfus, aber man kann damit
was anfangen. Was jetzt richtig abgedreht
wird, ist folgendes.
Äh,
das da.
Und zwar, anstatt
dass die in ihrer,
ich zeig's euch mal, wenn man das, wenn man das
das CSV
öffnet. Ups, wir sollten
vielleicht mal das CSV öffnen, wo was drinne steht.
Wenn man das CSV öffnet,
dann sieht man, dass die
auf die, dass die auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen sind,
den Status dieser
Meldung, ähm,
als, als Text reinzuschreiben.
Also, der,
der, der Status
ändert sich je nach ausgewählter
Sprache.
Das ist, das ist ziemlich
ätzend zu programmieren.
Ich mein, gut, wir verwenden immer Englisch,
ja, aber es wäre deutlich
schöner, wenn da einfach ein Status-Code drinne
stehen würde, und wir könnten das anhand der Liste
hier oben irgendwo anhand des Status-Codes
checken. Das heißt,
was wir jetzt machen müssen, ist, wir müssen diese ewig lange
Tabelle hier nehmen,
wo drinne steht, was jede einzelne
mögliche Status in jeder
einzel unterstützten Sprache
bedeutet.
Wir ignorieren mal Lettländisch, Ekländisch
und, und Litauisch.
Ignorieren wir mal.
Wir nehmen mal nur Englisch, das heißt,
wir müssen jeden Status,
weil wir ja keinen Code bekommen, wir bekommen ja
nur den Text,
müssen wir jeden Status, ähm,
mappen auf einen Status
von uns.
Also, das wird dann ein ganz schön langes
Switch-Statement,
mit irgendwie 18 oder so,
18 verschiedenen Einträgen drinne.
Ähm, das ist auch schon mal
richtig, ja. Und das
programmieren wir jetzt.
Wir programmieren jetzt mal eine Runde
DPD-AP.
Das wird, wird toll.
Ähm, also das heißt, dazu muss man,
was wir jetzt machen müssen,
ach ja, und ich habe noch
den Bonus, den Bonus habe ich ja noch
vergessen, den wollte ich auch noch machen, ist,
ähm, wir werden
die, die Stadt, die wir hier
rauskriegen, ja, kommt dann sowas wie
Freiburg oder, oder Mal, kommt dann
raus. Die Stadt
werden wir Reverse-Look-Uppen
zu einer,
zu einer, zu einer
Koordinate, die man dann auf einer Karte
anzeigen lassen kann.
Äh,
Alf, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob was du dich, ob was du dich liest jetzt.
Also genau, wir werden das dann,
wir werden die Stadt, also die hier, in dem Fall
äh, Freiburg.de und Mal.de
werden wir Reverse-Look-Uppen
per, per, über eine
Geo-AP
und uns quasi
Koordinaten auf einer, auf einer
Karte generieren lassen, die wir dann
speichern können, dass ich dann wiederum im
Webfrontend anzeigen lassen kann,
bei jeder Station, also sprich,
äh,
ich muss,
ich muss den Versandtraxer gerade nochmal starten,
dass ich es euch zeigen kann, was ich meine.
Versandtraxer,
starte mal.
Der Versandtraxer geht
übrigens trotzdem.
Genau, weil ich will hier eine Karte
anzeigen lassen können, wenn man nämlich
die Informationen hat. Wie gesagt, das Frontend
ist eh noch nicht Final, das gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht so gut.
Da kann ich hier eine Karte dann zu anzeigen lassen,
wenn ich dann weiß, ok, das ist jetzt gerade in Freiburg,
kann man hier noch quasi einen Kartenausschnitt
anzeigen lassen, man hat ja genug Platz im Endeffekt
auf der Seite,
wo das gerade ist. Das bringt
jetzt nicht so wirklich was, weil
ich mein, jemand der
dort wohnt, wird wissen, dass er dort
wohnt, aber ich glaube
so eine Ansicht auf einer Map ist eigentlich ganz
ähm, ganz
nützlich, weil du ungefähr einschätzen kannst, wie weit
das Ganze noch weg ist.
Ach so, ja, das könnte man auch
machen.
Allerdings, wir brauchen es ja nur in einer Stelle.
Aber wir können da auch eine Map
machen. Das macht eigentlich
in dem Fall wenig Unterschied. Ja, das können wir auch machen.
Nicht so.
Kommt noch das Gleiche raus.
Ja.
So sieht's aus, Leute.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Machen wir mal für SunTrack so wieder zu.
Ja, also
wir müssen jetzt machen, wir müssen Jason
API abfragen von DPD, CSV
API abfragen, die ganzen Informationen
extra hier. Ähm.
Programmierst du das für
Hardware? Nee.
Das hat damit nichts zu tun.
Das Hardware-Tool ist
schon lange da in Benutzung.
So. Und
Genau, Jason API abfragen, CSV API abfragen,
das Zeug alles extra hier
und dann
den Look abmachen.
So, ähm, ich hab das ehrlich gesagt mit Open
Street Map noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich weiß schon
welchen Geo, Geo Map, äh, nicht Geo,
wie heißt Geo Code Dienst wir
verwenden.
Die Städte bei der DPD API sind nicht so 100%
korrekt. Ja gut, ich mein,
wir können nur das anzeigen, was uns die API zurückliefert.
Im Zweifelfall ist es halt verkehrt,
aber wir können immer noch sagen, es ist nicht unser Problem.
Wir können nichts dafür. DPD
verliefert das Falsche zurück.
Okay, also, ähm,
wir erstellen uns jetzt mal schnell, oder ich kopiere mir das
einfach.
Ich kopiere mir mal zwei Sachen aus dem anderen Projekt
rüber, habe ich nämlich hier gerade auf dem
Zwei-In-Bild-Schirm auf. Ähm,
das da.
Das brauchen wir nämlich, das sind die Klassen,
die wir auch im Versand, im Versand-Tracker
drinne haben, ne?
Shipment-Status, ähm,
ups, vielleicht sollte ich es an die richtige Stelle kopieren.
Also das sind die Sachen, die, die
aus dem Versand-Tracker kommen.
Neuer Shipment-Status,
Shipment-Progress, äh,
Shipment-Tracker, das haben wir alles,
das ist, das kommt alles aus der Versand,
Versand-Tracker-Anwendung.
Das hab ich jetzt einfach nur rüber kopiert.
Weil, ähm, der Tracker kommt hier dann später
in, in, in die
größere Anwendung rein.
Da brauchen wir den ganzen Kram wieder.
Okay, also, dann fangen wir mal an.
Wir brauchen eine Klasse für den, äh,
DPD.
Und der
kriegt als Interface
iShipment-Tracker, habe ich das Ganze mal genannt.
Das ist ganz nützlich, weil
wir können das dann so machen,
ähm,
auskalt.
Ich mach, ich mach verschiedene Projekte,
dass ich, dass ich ausprobieren kann.
Ich find's immer blöd, in einem schon bestehenden
Projekt, neues Zeug, wo man noch nicht weiß, wie es genau funktioniert,
auszuprobieren.
Ähm,
ja, und der Sinn von dem Interface in dem Fall
ist, dass wir, äh,
quasi nicht intern
alle möglichen Tracker, die wir kennen,
wissen müssen.
Sondern, dass wir einfach gucken können
nach allen Klassen, die iShip,
iShipment-Tracker haben.
Und die laden wir dann einfach und
können sie verwenden.
Das macht's, das macht's halt deutlich,
deutlich einfacher.
Als, äh, dass ich dann in meiner,
in meiner Background, also die, die,
die Klasse, die im Hintergrund die ganzen
Trackingwerte abfragt, müsste ich dann immer sagen
New DPD-Tracker, New DHL-Tracker,
New Hermes-Tracker, New Amazon-Tracker.
Und ich müsste die Dinger alle kennen.
Könnte ja auch sein, dass ich, äh,
irgendwann mal auf die Idee komme
und, ähm, sage,
ich will jetzt irgendwie, äh, Mail.ru,
ne, warte mal, das ist ein Mail-Anbieter, das ist
eine Post. Keine Ahnung, ich will,
ich will, äh, China, China
Airmail implementieren.
Und, äh, ich will allerdings ja nicht meine,
meine, meine Tracking-Klasse anpassen, sondern
ich will einfach eine Klasse implementieren.
Äh, China, China-Tracker,
iShipment-Tracker, gut ist.
Ja, über Reflection werde ich das machen.
Also ich werde dann einfach gucken, äh,
ich lade dann einfach alle, alle
CS-Dateien in einem Verzeichnis,
oder mal gucken, wie man das machen, genau, muss ich mir
noch überlegen, und, äh, schaue mir zu Reflection
einfach, welche iShipment-Tracker haben,
und dann, dann ist gut.
Dann wird das aufgehoben.
Ähm,
wir machen dann vielleicht noch eine Methode,
wo man nachgucken kann, ob dieser
jeweilige Tracker sich überhaupt,
äh, für den jeweiligen Anbieter
zuständig fühlt, müssen wir mal schauen,
was wir machen, wenn wir so weit sind.
Okay, also das einzige,
was der DPD-Tracker machen muss,
das als einzige nach außen hin ist,
der braucht eine Methode,
die heißt
Track, der kriegt eine Tracking-Nummer
übergeben, und er gibt
uns eine History zurück,
von einzelnen Schritten bei der
Paketverfolgung.
Also, vom,
vom Interface her
ist es relativ simpel,
aber das zu implementieren
wird jetzt noch ein bisschen,
bisschen
komplizierter.
Okay, ähm, wir machen, wir machen
als erstes mal, wir nennen es mal Red, letztens
hat mir irgendwie einer erzählt, er steht, er steht auf
Variablen, die Red heißen.
Ähm,
so.
Und das returnen wir mal, dass das Ding,
dass wir das Ding komplizieren können.
Dann rufen wir es bei uns in, rufen
wir es in Main auf,
dass wir gucken können, ob es auch prinzipiell
funktioniert. Exit,
bla, bla, bla.
Tracker, DPD,
Tracker. So, dann braucht hier,
hier muss die, die Versandnummer
rein. Versandnummer
vom Eichler kommt da jetzt rein.
Ich glaub, das ist vom Eichler gewesen.
So, ähm,
und dann,
...
Ach so, was mach ich da für einen Blödsinn?
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Weg, so, da kommt die nochmal rein.
Ähm,
Result,
bla,
und dann machen wir eine Schleife mit den
Ergebnissen.
So, und geben hier mal irgendwie
keine Ahnung, geben wir mal aus, was er gefunden hat.
Stadt,
die er gefunden hat,
ähm,
Message, die er gefunden hat, bei
DPD,
Status,
und als letztes haben wir dann noch
Zeit.
Dann machen wir eben so ein
Brennen,
Brennen
durch drunter, gut.
So, wenn wir das jetzt ausführen, passiert ja
genau genommen gar nichts.
Er startet, es sagt Exit, ich stelle
den Knopf, ist weg.
Auch gut so.
...
Ich mein wir unterstützen aktuell eh nur vier oder vier oder fünf anbieter das heißt man kann auch ohne probleme
Zur compile zeit wirst du das ja wissen nicht unbedingt nicht unbedingt ja
Also zumindest nicht unbedingt zur compile zeit von
Von der klasse die dann das background tracking macht oder ich will ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Die klasse anpassen dass der die kennt
Also ich finde das mit ich finde das über reflection und dem interface eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
Da findet man ansonsten muss ich quasi jedes mal alles anpassen das kann man sich jetzt da kann man sich jetzt schon drüber streiten wie
Man das macht aber ich finde im prinzip so so oder so ähnlich funktionieren alle plug-in systeme unter dort nicht
Also wenn du jetzt irgendwelche sachen hast wo wo du also wenn wenn das programm fertig ist du kannst dazu irgendwelche erweiterungen basteln
Dann machen die das alle so oder so ähnlich die haben dann interface iplugin was mit 5-6 verschiedenen methoden hat so nach dem motto
post run hook, prerun hook, sonst was
Vielleicht machen wir es auch noch anders
Ist egal wir müssen jetzt erstmal das
Das ist egal wir müssen erst mal dpd ansteuern
Als erstes brauchen wir den htp client dass wir dpd abfragen können
Kann man in sich ab bei einer sealed class per reflection subclasses abfragen
Du kannst bei einer sealed class keine subclass machen oder wie meinst du das jetzt
Oder meinst du wenn du subclass und die dann zielst
Vielleicht habe ich vorhin was verpasst aber kannst du das nehmen weiß ich nicht vielleicht habe ich das schlicht ergreifend nicht gesehen was ist das denn
Ja heil schon mal her
Ach cool warst du das her das habe ich bei denen nicht gefunden
Ich dachte also alles was ich bei dpd gefunden habe ist dass man dass man einen kompletten
Also wenn man die offizielle api verwendet braucht man api code
Oder hast du das von der webseite von dem? Ach das hast du von der von der von der tracking webseite
von der sendeverfolgungs webseite
Oder
Das könnte man verwenden
Das könnte man verwenden allerdings würde ich lieber für diesen tracker
Zumindest halbwegs offizielle api verwenden
Als die hier weil das ist ja quasi eine interne api die die das frontend von dpd verwendet
Da kann sich jederzeit was dran ändern und das andere ist immerhin
Eine offizielle api mit einem offiziellen api dokument auch wenn die api ekelig ist wird die sich wahrscheinlich nicht
Morgen mal ändern das hier kann sich ja theoretisch jederzeit jederzeit ändern
Wenn die da wenn die da meinung sind dass das hier jetzt keine ahnung noch mal noch mal in den error reinkommen soll
Dann ist das morgen so die haben wir hier im prinzip
Keine verpflichtung ihre ihre ihre frontend ihre webseiten frontend api irgendwie so
Zu gestalten oder so beizubehalten dass das andere weiterverwenden können außer ihr frontend
Kann man aber machen also ist wahrscheinlich sogar schöner zu verwenden
Aber wir benutzt jetzt mal die offizielle dpd api wo man keine api braucht
So als erstes brauchen wir einen
Würdest du dann einfach unter allen geladenen klassen nach den trackern suchen oder in einem ordner auf dem file
Wenn ich wirklich komplett sagen wir mal
plugin mäßig extended haben will dann würde ich im ordner nach nach files suchen
Plugin mäßig extended haben will dann würde ich im ordner nach nach files suchen
Bei mir nachdem ich ja keine externen plugins haben will bei mir könnte es sogar sein dass ich im geladenen
Geladenen schon suche vielleicht mache ich es auch ganz anders es klingt mir jetzt aber erst mal sinnvoll so zu machen
Bei mir nachdem ich keine externen plugins haben will bei mir könnte es sogar sein dass ich im geladenen geladenen schon suche vielleicht mache ich es auch ganz anders
es klingt mir jetzt aber erst mal sinnvoll so zu machen
So also wir brauchen erstmal eine dp klein also hier beatport wenn du irgendwelche guten vorschläge dafür hast das muss man muss man so nicht machen
So also wir brauchen erstmal eine dp klein also hier beatport wenn du irgendwelche guten vorschläge dafür hast das muss man müssen wir so nicht machen
Letztendlich machen wir es ja auch auf jeden Fall nicht einfach so
So also wir brauchen erstmal eine dp klein also hier beatport wenn du irgendwelche guten vorschläge dafür hast das muss man muss man so nicht machen
So also wir brauchen erstmal eine dp klein also hier beatport wenn du irgendwelche guten vorschläge dafür hast das muss man so nicht machen
Letztendlich machen wir es ja auch auf jeden Fall nicht einfach so
So wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben wir haben wieder schon so viel gesetzt wir brauchen die Uhrl von dem Service der ist da
Das ist die Jason Uhrl wobei brauchen wir die Uhrl eigentlich müssen wir die ganz global hinschreiben aber machen wir anders
Wir laden uns jetzt erstmal das Jason Zeug runter
Geht es euch allen gut ja mir schon und dem Chat auch weil der Chat ist cute Chat
Ja String, Async
Gut dann laden wir
Ich hätte das nicht alles kopieren sollen oh fuck
Was hast du eigentlich mittlerweile für den Sub-Count?
Ich weiß es gar nicht, ich guck mal nach, wahrscheinlich so 130 oder 140 oder sowas.
141, Pock!
Genau 2 Millionen, der deutsche Ninja am Start.
Wir machen mal eine eigene Methode für, und zwar, das Einzige was ich von dieser Jason
Api will, ist ja abfragen, ob es einen Fehler gibt, mehr will ich nicht.
Also machen wir mal hier irgendwas so public, äh nicht public, private, bool, äh check
vor error oder sowas.
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst ja, ich bin im Benamen von Sachen ganz, ganz toll.
So und dann kopieren wir das mal rein, weil die können wir dann auch Async machen, dann
machst du das, so check for error, blablabla, get await, dann machen wir das hier mal raus,
machen wir hier all, gleich, machen wir hier rein, dass das alles ein bisschen kürzer ist.
So, da kann man das nämlich schon gleich wieder viel schöner lesen.
Hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Achso ja, return true, das gibt einfach immer Fehler.
Äh, was hat er für Schmerzen hier?
Warum mag er nicht?
Achso, Alter, warum, vielleicht soll ich das auch mal da drinnen schreiben anstatt da oben
irgendwo, ne?
Da in the fuck man, genau, und wenn es Async ist, müssen wir einen task tool zurückgeben.
Geht das nicht?
Ok, wait, flop, string, alles gut.
Jetzt geben, jetzt lassen wir uns mal den, das result ausgeben, das sollte jetzt hier
einfach der JSON string sein von, von diesem Paket, wir haben übrigens das falsche Paket
ausgewählt, das ist unser Testpaket, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wenn wir fertig entwickeln
sind, sind wir bei DPD erstmal geblacklistet, komplett geblacklistet.
Gurnamen, was hacksaust du heute?
Äh, die DPD API, wobei ich hacksaue die nicht, ich verwende die offizielle API Dokumentation,
die ich hier gefunden habe, auch wenn die sehr merkwürdig ist und beinhaltet, dass
wir in ein CSV parsen müssen.
Wow, Alter, Sebaro, was jetzt los?
Hast du, gab's Gehalt oder was?
Pock?
Alter, huge, was ist da los, äh, genau, der Sebaro.
Zehn Stufe eins Subs, okay, zehnmal klicken, den haben wir da, das Sebaro verschenkt an,
das ist ja lustig, äh, Beatbrod, ich wollte dir grad ein Abo schenken.
Ähm, und ich hab festgestellt, dass ich meine eigenen Abos bezahlen muss, dann verschenke
ich doch kein Abo, big brain, ne?
Ich dachte, ich könnte es jetzt einfach anklicken und du kriegst eins, nachdem ich meine eigenen
Abos bezahlen muss, ähm, mach ich's dann doch nicht.
Stimmt, aber kriegste zwei Euro zurück, oh, das ist big brain, also im Prinzip, wenn
ich selbst einen Subs, einen Subscription gifte, bedeutet das eigentlich, ich bezahle
an Twitch zwei fünfzig, oder, weil zwei fünfzig krieg ich wieder, der Beatbrod, Sebaro, jetzt
übertreibst du mal nicht, äh, jetzt übertreibst du mal nicht, Pock, huge, was ist da los,
ja?
Da hab ich den richtigen gemoddet, ich bin da, ich bin da komplett sell-out, ja, also
wenn einer fünfzig Subscriber gifte oder so, kriegt der Instant Mod, guck mich nicht, sell-out,
easy, easy sell-out, easy live, hab kein Ding.
Fast nur Subs hier im Chat, ja, also Pock, ich muss echt sagen, ich find, ich find das,
also der Chat ist, wie gesagt, wir haben ja auch hier Q-Chat am Start und ich find's
super, das ist, in jedem Stream sind, sind, sind sehr oft die gleichen Leute, ja, das
find ich, find ich sehr nice, weil wenn ich hier so durch guck, ich kenn, ich kenn fast,
fast jeden hab ich schon mal gesehen, den StephKris hab ich schon, den YoYo hab ich
schon öfters gesehen, Gelora hab ich auch schon öfters gesehen, der Enderboy ist auch
schon am Start, ganz schön Sneaky, Pock, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Twitch Prime, ähm, Twitch
Prime SS Service, ja, wen haben wir denn hier sonst noch, den Beatbrot, den hab ich auch
schon gesehen, der Moonbier ist auch öfters mal am Start, dann haben wir, ähm, den Patrick
da ist natürlich auch, der Sebaro E, ähm, der Kalf ist auch am Start öfters, der Boss
FTW ist auch da, der Milchmann ist auch oft da, Void Danny haben wir auch schon öfters
gesehen, Boss FTW auch, ähm, Airworker ist auch öfters am Start, Tribolone ist auch
öfters am Start, Gluttona ist öfters am Start, Sideline hab ich heute, glaub ich, zum ersten
Mal gesehen, ganz schön Sneaky hab ich auch, glaub ich, zum ersten Mal gesehen, der Haze
sagt mir auch nix, den haben wir sonst noch hier, der Daniel ist auch öfters da, Cry
CSC, den, der Name sagt mir auch was, der Kwai ist auch öfters da, so, jetzt, ich scroll
jetzt nicht den ganzen Chat, natürlich, weil alles da ist, aber, ähm, der Haze, ja, das
kann natürlich sein, ich, äh, sag mal so, ich, ich seh natürlich nur die Leute, die
schreiben, ne, ich hab ja keine Zuschauerliste, gibt's bei Twitch eigentlich auch Analytics
von Zuschauern, äh, ich glaube schon, hab ich mir aber noch nie angeguckt, ich glaube,
dass es sowas gibt, der Matt ist auch öfters dabei, ja, das stimmt, okay, machen wir weiter
schon, 20 Uhr, sonst, mittags, heute, sonst, sonst kommen wir heute wieder nicht über
zwei Zeilen, hallo, Welt, raus, ähm, okay, weiter im Text, hier, aufrufen, das ganze,
check for error, ID, okay, gucken wir, ob da jetzt, ob da jetzt, ja, passt, okay, Jason
hier, das, gibt's, das, das geht, ja, OANenergy pi, den Na byrrite kriegst jetzt zum
auf den wir eh warten müssen
das ist eigentlich overkill
können wir einfach mal sagen, result gut ist
das ist egal, ich hab letztens in webcast gesehen
dass man result
nicht verwenden soll, sondern
get a waiter, get result
weil es dann automatisch
die exception falls es eine gibt unwrapped
aber ich finde das so unleserlich, ich schreib immer
result
weil best practice
so siehts aus
subscriben ist eindeutig
best practice
also sozusagen
das dann
zars, subscriber as a service
saben ist nicht nur huge
brain, das ist 2000
IQ
so wie viele
subs haben wir jetzt eigentlich
das hab ich eben gerade geguckt
voll die übersicht verloren
ah, das
streamlabs hat es noch gar nicht mit gekriegt
oder
10 subs
gegiftet und dann gleich wieder gecancelt
aber ich glaube das geht gar nicht
ich glaube man kann gegiftete subs nicht canceln
wie viele subs sind
es schon, eben war es 141
jetzt müssten es so 13 mehr sein
also die 150 haben wir geknackt
das heißt wir haben sogar glaube ich
mittlerweile schon ein weiteres emote freigeschaltet
also jetzt hab ich quasi
ein emote mehr
was ich nicht verwenden, verwendet habe
ich hab ja noch gar kein emote
das einzige was wir haben ist das subbatch
das ist auch ein geiles
Satz
aber ich kann das glaube ich nur schwer
charge becken
patrick
eine, das heißt ihr kriegt jetzt einen
lowlevel programming drill
bei euch, das ist natürlich
sehr pock
ok
weiter im text
das dauert schon wieder
wir gucken jetzt ob in dem result
error gesetzt ist
oh ich glaube wir sind
geplacklistet, guck mal wie lange das dauert
guck mal wie lange das dauert
kann es sein dass
sie uns geplacklistet haben oder so was
in der richtung
ach klatsch ich rufe das ganze gar nicht auf
ich bin ja auch hier
hardcore ppega
sub
also guck mal wenn check error
wenn das
true zurück liefert
dann
dann gehen wir
erstmal raus
und liefern
nichts zurück
wenn das den error hat, wir könnten allerdings
auch eine error message
wozu den dpd tracker
das kann ich dir zeigen wir basteln
ein eigenes tracking tool
was aktuell allerdings nur
dhl kann
habe es jetzt leider nicht auf glaube ich
ne ich starte es mal
der versand track
die network marketing
mucke, keine ahnung das ist eine
8 stunden playlist auf
youtube
genau wir haben hier einen versand tracker der aktuell nur dhl
kann, der kann dir sagen wo dann
zeug ist
und kann dir benachrichtigungen schicken
und der eigentliche trick dabei ist
weil versand tracker wo du
manuell sachen hinzufügen
gibt es ja wie sand am mer das ist ja nichts neues
was mir allerdings
fehlt ist das versand tracker
der sich automatisch
die bestellungen die ich gemacht habe einsammeln
kann zum beispiel
aus einem email postfach
und das dann für mich tracked und mir immer
bescheid sagt
das basteln wir gerade
das heißt wir können ja nicht einfach
die webseite von dpd verwenden weil da können wir nicht automatisch
gescheit auswerten damit
prime sub
fast flex
hast du vor den tracker in einem store anzubieten
den gibt es kostenlos auf github dann
falscher sound
auch stimmt falscher sound
ok
ich muss mich jetzt mal konzentrieren weiter im text
wir rufen den kram ab
genau da haben wir das auch so
jetzt müssen wir den jason kram parsen
dürfte auch relativ easy
sein den jason kram
zu parsen
das sagen wir jetzt einfach mal
dass ich jason
gleich j-object
j-object
ok wir müssen
ich kann nicht mal schreiben ey
j-object
oh
da müssen wir den jason parser
mal installieren im hintergrund
ja mr milchmann
das kenne ich
ich gehe auch immer
wenn ich was machen will auf twitch
lasse twitch nebenbei laufen
und dann stelle ich fest
ich mache nichts mehr wenn ich twitch gucke
wir parsen jetzt
das jason
in den jason-object
und dann
holen wir uns
den error key da raus
das war ja relativ
ich zeige es nochmal
result
das war relativ einfach
achso ich müsste vielleicht auch mal
einen code eingeben der einen Fehler produziert
oh ich hab
ich hab den scheiß da noch
hardcoded drin
ok moment
paket nochmal
das machen wir hinten hin
damit ihr wisst
bei nullparametern ist die reihenfolge
ziemlich egal
plus id
ok
und jetzt produzieren wir mal
guck mal ob es auch funktioniert
hallo nimbulow
error reading object
ok es gibt ja auch keinen fehler
jetzt müssen wir uns das error
ob
oder auch nicht
wo ist das problem
das ist doch super
super simples jason
das soll es doch gar kein problem geben
warum kann er das nicht parsen
das ist doch vollkommen standard hier
detail error
code
no status found
for your shipment
program
ich lese program immer einmal am tag komplett durch
weiß ich Bescheid
ah muss man wissen
und danach die üblichen anderen
sicher
hat die sharp eigentlich auch probleme
wenn man viele strings miteinander
konkettet ja hat es
aber das müssen schon sehr viele sein
also wenn du eine schleife machst
keine ahnung eins bis
20 Milliarden
und machst da drin jedes mal
ein plus dann ist es langsam aber du kannst einfach einen string
bilder verwenden
und ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es noch was
anderes aber früher hat man immer einen string
bilder verwenden dann ist es schnell
also und nachdem ich nachdem ich
program gelesen habe muss ich
lesen reddit was
letzte preis
seh ich auch immer gern
das sind screenshots von ebay klein anzeigen
was letzte preis
da kommen dann so dinger wie
kostet 70
kostet 40 Euro sind Dinger
für 40 Euro zu haben ja das war jetzt nicht so
lustig
egal das guck ich mir dann auch
auf das was letzte preis
reddit 600 Euro
das kenne ich nicht
was ich auch noch ab und zu mal lese ist
wenn mir die leute im Zug so sehr auf den sack gegangen ist
dieses wie heißt das
dieses ich hasse Kinder
reddit muss ich alle drüber
auslassen wie kacke Kinder sind vor allem
im Zug also nicht vor allem
im Zug so generell wie kacke Kinder sind dann
kommen dann auch ab und zu leute die sind
die haben etwas nennen wir es mal etwas
radikale ansichten die
schreiben dann so dinger wie
ich hasse Kinder und lasse mich
kastrieren und sowas denke
ich mir auch immer ok gut dass du uns das auf reddit
mitteilst wollte ich schon immer
mal wissen ich meine
das ist eigentlich die logische konsequenz ja
eigentlich ist
das gar nicht dumm eigentlich ist das next level
wo
ist jetzt eigentlich genau das problem dass der link
wo genau ist jetzt das problem dass der
mein jason nicht passen kann
error code
ist doch vollkommen
ok error
ach das ist doch mal in einem error
drin ah
das war ok
wundert mich bei dpd wundert mich nichts mehr
also müssen wir nicht j object
passen sondern
j array müssen wir
passen
ähm
und danach
das erste
das erste raus holen
und dann sollte das eigentlich auch funktionieren
wenn ich den error jetzt ausgab
ja funktioniert
code start aus 200
so das heißt wir können jetzt sagen
return
ob error null ist
oder nicht also sprich wenn error null ist
wenn wenn error null ist
haben wir hier return
was ich hier
string null was haben wir hier null
white space
error
dann
so das war es einfach so hier
so string
ach ne moment
ha stopp stopp stopp
stimmt nicht so genau da war doch noch was
da war doch noch was drinne
ähm
ja error code fabrizieren
ach ich muss ich muss
ähm
achso ne passt
passt wenn es
null ist dann haben wir
kein error so einfach
so
der guckt jetzt
gibt es einen Fehler
wenn es einen Fehler gibt
meist dann error
können wir mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert
ähm
ach gucken wir mal hier
error
print debug beste
wer braucht
debugger
ja error
error funktioniert
gut
und dann returnen wir das ganze einfach
ne
wir müssen noch einen status
reinschreiben ok also
adden wir einen neuen status
ein shipment progress
hier so
da schreiben wir jetzt rein also wir wissen
ja wenn da ein Fehler auftritt wissen wir
dass das ding location
haben wir keine ahnung message haben wir keine
ahnung status wissen wir
aber der status ist auf jeden fall
invalid
hä ach
komm mal dran machen
also wenn es einen Fehler gibt
ist der status auf jeden fall invalid und
updated add ist
ja gut jetzt gerade in dem moment wo er
abgefragt hat
wisst ihr was wir noch machen könnten
wir konnten äh
heute ist eigentlich cool heute kann ich mich ganz gut konzentrieren
da kommt man ein bisschen
vorwärts
ähm
wir könnten die
wir könnten hier noch die error
nachrichten zurückgeben also sowas wie hier
out
mess
add
ach moment geht
gar nicht hier war an der stelle string
message
error
so ähm
error message ist
leer
kommt aufs gleiche raus
ähm da machen wir das return back
jetzt sagen wir if
wenn
überlegen
wenn es
keinen Fehler gibt
also hier wollen wir
auf jeden fall schon mal return false
ne wenn es einen Fehler gibt
so rum wenn es einen Fehler gibt
also wenn da was
drinne steht wenn es einen Fehler gibt
dann wollen wir die
error message
äh die error message mit zurückgeben
also error message
error
message
string
return true
so
so müsste das funktionieren
und hier sagen wir jetzt war
wo ist das problem
äh
war
error message
oder error einfach nur
sogar gut dass ich das error message gehört hab
da unten hieß das ding hieß schon mal error
ähm
und dann
können wir jetzt nämlich die message
message zuweisen
nämlich error message
das ist übrigens ein neues die sharp 7 feature
dass man quasi
ähm das direkt zuweisen
kann eine variable und das dann auch gleich in dem if
also direkt
inline machen kann
das ist ganz nützlich
übrigens ich bin grad relativ konzentriert
wenn ich über irgendwelche
wenn ich Fragen komplett über sehe es bleibt
mich einfach mal ein bisschen zu so ok
jetzt kriegen wir hier schon mal was ordentliches
zurück haben wir sollten auch eine status
message zurück kriegen genau
no status is found for your shipment
status invalid
aktuelle uhrzeit
sehr gut
das gefällt mir schon mal
glaube ich hier mal das debug wieder raus machen
ok weiter
jetzt kommt diese komische csv ap
jetzt kommt diese csv ap
ich guck mal ob ich im chat irgendwas drin hab
im chat ist überhaupt nichts drinne
also chat ist äh
Diskussion am start aber ich wurde nicht erwähnt
das heißt ich ignoriere das jetzt mal bis
da irgendwas kommt
ähm gut also
jetzt müssen wir diese komische csv ap mal
ans hapfen
also war
csv http
client
get string
und zwar brauchen wir jetzt
von dieser url das ganze
und zwar wo ist die
wo ist die csv ap
da ist die csv ap
kommt euch das auch so komisch vor
csv ap zu sagen
es gibt keine
niemand macht
csv aps
außerdem war dpd
jetzt auch genau
ok ähm dann gehen wir das csv mal aus
gucken ob das funktioniert
achso
vielleicht sollte ich auch die nummer anpassen
ah vielleicht
achso das ding ist nicht
nicht erst so
ja da steht da guck da haben wir unser
unser super hübsches äh
super hübsches csv
wir parsen das von hand oder
wir holen wir
wir laden uns jetzt keine csv library oder so runter
ich mein im endeffekt müssen wir das obere
müssen wir eigentlich
die erste zeile wegschmeißen
die nächste zeile splitten und irgendwie das
Feld rausnehmen das Feld rausnehmen
und das Feld rausnehmen
da brauchen wir keine
extra csv library für
ähm
was genau
ist eigentlich der use case von out
parametern also in welchen konkreten fall
sind die nützlich
äh zum beispiel genau für sowas hier also in der
regel wenn du mehr als einen rückgabewert
brauchst sind die ganz praktisch
ähm wo das
in dotnet relativ oft verwendet
wird ist sowas hier trypass
hast du eine funktion trypass
die äh gibt dir
dann halt ein out parameter also da übergibst
du dann irgendwie was weiß ich das zum
parsen und kriegst dann ein out
parameter zurück der dir dann quasi
das ähm
Ergebnis
von diesem
parsvorgang gibt und
ähm du kannst allerdings hier an dem
eigentliche rückgabewert erkennen ob das funktioniert
hat also im prinzip ein bisschen sowas
wie wie hier oben
du guckst ob es ein fehler ist
ob es ein fehler gibt und wenn es
quasi einen fehler gegeben hat oder wenn hier was drin
steht dann kannst du es gleich verwenden
es gibt
aber mehrere möglichkeiten
ähm exceptions
ich will ja keine exceptions werfen
ich
das ist vollkommen ok wenn es
ein fehler gibt wenn es einen fehler gibt
eine exception werfe ich wenn die webseite nicht erreichbar ist
aber wenn es einen fehler gibt
ist ok das ist ja auch ein gültiger
status der fehler besagt
in dem fall die tracking nummer
stimmt nicht
ja
wenn du jetzt keine verbindung zur webseite kriegst
dann kannst du eine exception werfen oder die exception
nicht abfangen vom arttp client
es gibt noch eine also es gibt noch ein paar
andere varianten
wie man mehrere rückgabeparameter
machen kann in zicht ab du kannst
ein tuppel zurückgeben mit mehreren
rückgabeparametern du kannst natürlich
in der klasse basteln oder irgendwie ein struct
wo du es zurück gibst
oder was es jetzt ganz neu gibt ist es gibt
jetzt offiziellen support für mehrere rückgabeparameter
den verwende ich aber
so gut wie nie der sieht der sieht so aus
ich muss mal gucken ob ich das jetzt zusammen
kriege der sieht der sieht
ungefähr
test
der sieht ungefähr so aus ich probiere das mal
zusammenzufüllen
ähm mehrere return parameter wie
ging das bool
ja eins oder irgendwie
was weiß ich
das da
und dann string
das hier
irgendwie so ging das
aber die syntax ist natürlich
komplett falsch wie ich sie gerade verwendet
so
ah das sieht schon
besser aus
genau das ist auch ein tuppel intern
aber das schöne ist dass das quasi dann
auch richtig benannt ist also sprich
wenn ich wenn ich das hier dann aufrufe
also wir rufen das jetzt nicht auf wir gucken bloß die
intellisens dazu an wenn ich das hier dann
aufrufe
dann sehe ich hier
als return
als returnwert
sehe ich die dinger schon da drinnen
meine zwei returnwerte und auch
richtig benannt
das ist quasi
die neueste variante wie man mehrere returnwerte
haben kann unter der haube ist das aber
auch ein tuppel was
automatisch quasi geunboxed wird
das ist einfach syntaktisch
ein bisschen schöner das hätten wir hier auch
machen können wir hätten auch hier ohne
probleme sagen können bool irgendwas
geht genauso geht
ganz genau
mittlerweile ist die sharp
eh so eine sprache wo manche
Sachen tatsächlich auf
tatsächlich auf
mehr als eine
art und weise
doch gemacht oder
error message
gleich
ring empty
ah gut
perfekt die sharp wird
zu c++ davon sind wir wirklich
zum glück noch meilenweit entfernt
das wäre das da
dann würde ich würde ich keine ahnung
zu rust
wechseln oder zu
go oder
zu
javascript eher nicht
ne zu java auch nicht
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich wirklich mehr ernsthaft
go angucken wenn das der fall ist
dann mach ich swift
swift mach ich
swift mach ich ab dann
oder ich mach kotlin unter java
oder java vm
das ist auch
kotlin hat sich auch sehr schön viele sachen von
die sharp abgeguckt von ruby abgeguckt von java
abgeguckt also
wirklich eine ganz hübsche
hübsche sache was ich bis jetzt
gesehen habe
rust ja doch rust ist auch sehr nice
ok also
wir haben das csv runtergeladen
was meinst du wie viele produktexporte preissuchmaschinen
in csv sind fragt der clocks hd
saumissig viele kann ich mir vorstellen
bei uns auf der arbeit gibt es
auch noch sauviele excel tabellen und csv
wo ich mir denke aber es sind im jahr 2019
muss das
echt sein
gut
also wir splitten das
jetzt mal das csv
wird jetzt mal gesplittet
an
u lines
wir splitten das an u lines
und dann sagen wir
the header
is lines ist die erste
zeile
dann haben wir
body
content
also die restlichen
zeilen data data
immer so schön nicht sagen
data
ok
ich glaube records heißt
bei csv
payload
payload ist ja alles
wisst ihr was das beste ist
wir nennen das einfach temp
wenn an den blicks einfällt
dann wird das ganze immer temp
v1
ne ne wir nennen es nicht temp
wir nennen es
content
wir nehmen einfach das erste was mir eingefallen ist
so und das
sind jetzt können wir ein tolles
csharp 8 feature verwenden
habe ich nämlich erst heute
morgen einen artikel drüber gelesen
und zwar csharp 8
kann jetzt range operator
also man kann jetzt hier sowas machen
eins bis ende
als man das so schreibt
da bin ich mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher
ob man das so schreibt
das ist neu
und das ist richtig praktisch
das ist wirklich cool
ansonsten wäre das gar nicht so einfach gewesen
ansonsten hätte ich hier irgendwie sowas sagen müssen
lines split
ne nicht lines array split
und
aber so ist das mit dem range operator
ist das richtig richtig
so
gehen wir mal content aus
gehen wir jetzt mal
content aus
ja content
und wir gucken mal ob ich das mit dem range operator richtig gemacht habe
einfach eins punkt punkt
ja echt
boh
geht das
gehts wirklich
eins punkt punkt sagste
eins punkt
ja das muss ich übernehmen das ist cool
das ist noch schöner
dachte es gibt vielleicht einen operator extra so nach dem motto von hinten
oder sowas
und jetzt sehe ich auch falsche ideen kommen chat
ich meine das array von hinten
aber so ist es natürlich noch besser
tata stre.. was
tata stresemann sagt
ach du warst der der den ryzen gewonnen hat genau
er schreibt er hat sein board geflasht und lief auf anhieb
das ist nice
ok
komm wie nennts records
der mist heißt
records in csv
also
4 record in records
wobei nee
denn record ist eine einzelne
eintrag aus einer zeile
das heißt
records
in things
genau
und den wollen wir jetzt
splitten
geht das net
kann ich das net splitten
ach so weil es mehrere zeilen sind
ok also sagen wir select
warum gibt es das
habe ich keinen link importiert kann das sein
ha
so
wir splitten jetzt
jede jede zeile
an weil ich meine das ist eine csv
das heißt wir splitten jede zeile
an
jede zeile
an einem comma
ich meine das ist halt csv
und csv muss man am
comma splitten
9flo96
was ist das in zeile 83
das ist ein c sharp 8 feature
das ist
range operator
das ist vom ersten element also
vom vom zweiten element
von logik her ja
von index 1 bis zum ende
des arrays
die range
also alle zeilen
vom ersten
von index 1 bis zum ende
comma oder semi-colon
es war glaube ich comma
es war comma
war comma
es war es war ziemlich sicher comma
wegen dem header den man überspringt genau
was ich jetzt nochmal mache
ist ich lasse mir das nochmal
ausgeben
und kopiere mir mal eine
Beispielausgabe
von dem csv
in mein in mein visual studio rein
dass ich mir merken kann wie die ausgabe aussieht
dass ich gleich weiß
welchefelder ich da
rausholen muss und welche nicht
ok
das sind doch nicht records
doch doch das sind records genau wir kriegen jetzt
ja hier wir kriegen jetzt hier einen array raus
mit
weil was mache ich denn da funktioniert das überhaupt
funktioniert das überhaupt
funktioniert das überhaupt was ich hier treibe
das war es shit
kommt mir hier raus
achja doch
wir haben genau wir haben
wir haben ein nummerable
mit einem string array drin also quasi
in einem array wenn man so will stimmt
ja das ergibt Sinn
wir
programmieren für unser tracking tool
den tracker für dpd
und dpd hat eine sehr merkwürdige api mit
die man parsen muss.
baumier1237, duitschbrei, dankeschön, nice.
also wenn man subscribt, kriegt man automatisch viel größeres hirn.
ich glaube das ist allen klar.
ok jetzt können wir uns das ganze raus, also wir haben jetzt quasi einen Array in einem
Array drinnen.
was auch wenn man ein sub geschenkt bekommt, ja ja ja wenn man ein sub geschenkt bekommt
ist es sogar so, dass beide hugebrain haben.
derjenige der den sub giftet und derjenige der den sub received, das ist quasi doppelbrain.
das ist das ist nicht hugebrain, das ist ich würde schon sagen fast massivebrain.
ja es ist auch schwierig sich hier auf den kram zu konzentrieren, chat zu lesen plus
sich noch zu merken was man da alles erzählt.
ok auf gehts, date, date ist das erste Feld, also das da, das ist date, next song, nächstes
Feld ist time, das da, dann haben wir als nächstes Feld city, das ist 01234, dann haben
wir als nächstes Feld was wir brauchen, die message, die message ist 012345.
so was wir jetzt noch machen müssen, wir müssen date und time parsen in ein datetime
objekt, weil wir sonst nicht ordentlich verarbeiten können, also hier datetime ist datetime pars
exakt, manche dotnet api sind ein bisschen merkwürdig, man würde normalerweise vermuten
dass man einfach sagen kann datetime pars, das funktioniert nicht, man muss sagen datetime
pars exakt, weil es nur microsoft, weil nur da kann man ein format string angeben was
man braucht.
als string wollen wir in dem fall unser date, wir parsen erstmal nur das date, das ist ein
bisschen doof, es ist 0702-2019, also Jahr, Tag, Monat, so und jetzt müssen wir angeben
wie das ganze formatiert ist, also sprich was welcher Buchstabe sagt, ich probiere das
jetzt mal ganz naiv und sage es ist Monat, Monat, Tag, Tag, Ja, Ja, aber das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren, was will er noch, will er noch mehr Parameter, Formatprovider braucht
sein, ich schaue mal ob das funktioniert, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, da muss ich jedes mal nachgucken
was die passenden Formatparameter sind, wie die Dinge heißen, gibt alles mögliche, Liste
funktioniert nicht, string 0702 was not recognized as valid datetime, also müssen wir auf die
Microsoft-Doco Seite gucken, Format, datetime, was es da alles gibt, hier ein schönes Beispiel,
also, ach MM ist minutes, ja ich will das haben, will großes M haben, will großes M haben
und dann, was ist day, day ist richtig und ja, here no leading zero, here leading zero,
ja, das war hier dran, hat ein Abonnerboy verschenkt, nice, Dankeschön, ja jetzt hat
sich das Gehirn quasi quasi verdoppelt gerade, ok also wahrscheinlich einfach nur groß machen
und dann geht's, ja wo ist denn das Problem, wo ist das Problem, warum geht das nicht,
das ist doch voll logisch, dass das geht, großes M ist Monat, wir haben da Monat vorne drin
stehen, dreimal Y ist, ja, haben wir auch, viermal Y ist ja, haben wir auch drin stehen
und kleines D ist der Tag, das muss auch stimmen, das ist richtig, wo ist das Problem, nochmal
date aus, mal gucken, vielleicht ist da Leerzeichen da vorne oder dahinter oder sowas, ach, das
sind Quotes drum herum, hier sind keine Quotes drum herum, wahrscheinlich filtert das Open
Office raus, also Replace Quotes durch nix, wobei das können wir, das könnten wir einfacher
haben, wir könnten direkt hier oben, könnten direkt hier oben nur replacen, hoff das funktioniert
jetzt noch, fuck, jetzt hab ich zu viel Replaced, Lowbrite, jetzt hab ich zu viel Replaced, ok
das funktioniert, wir replacen unten, wir replacen unten, Index war aus, Index war, das
ist die DPD Kacke, genau, eine Statusbeschreibung ein Komma enthält, denke ich, ich würde mal
sagen, eine Statusbeschreibung darf kein Komma enthalten, wo ist denn das, ja weil das ein
CSV ist, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass in einem CSV kein Komma vorkommen darf, außer wenn
man das trennen will, ist deshalb nicht alles in Quotes gerappt, kein Schimmer, ist das
Problem hier, ich glaube die DPD API ist einfach nur lahm gerade, innerhalb der Anführungszeichen
dürften Kommas vorkommen, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich nicht,
ob das erlaubt ist, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Anführungszeichen überhaupt einen tieferen
Sinn haben, no status found, ich glaube die DPD API mag nicht mehr, probier mal das als
dritten Parameter, wir haben gerade überhaupt nicht das Problem, dass das Parsen nicht funktioniert,
die DPD API liefert uns gerade keine Antwort, ich glaube wir wurden gerade gedrosselt oder
sowas, weil wir zu oft drauf zugegriffen haben, wir wüssten wahrscheinlich jetzt 2-3 Minuten
warten oder so, bis wir wieder drauf zugreifen können, wir können einfach mal eine andere,
ich hab doch noch eine andere, ich hab doch hier genug DPD Keys, jetzt gehts wieder, Vasiloys
1.9.5 Twitch Primes ab, Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir
das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays,
Pock, Dankeschön, so und jetzt machen wir das mal hier, Replays, Pock, Dankeschön,
gucken wie ich jetzt irgendwie 20 switch 20 zeilen in dem switch statement copy
paste oder
was wird denn hier schönes programmiert kann ich dir zeigen
wir haben den versand tracker programmiert so aus aktuell aktuell kann
er nur dhl der automatisch deine emails scannt nach neuen nach neuen versand
bestätigung von anbietern du kannst auch manuell hinzufügen wenn du willst
ja der scannt deine emails wenn du ihm das erlaubst natürlich du musst deine
email postfach hinterlegen aber es läuft bei dir lokal das ist jetzt nichts in
der cloud oder so das kann man lokal starten bei sich
wir gucken an dem email postfach nach ob es neue versand benachrichtigungen von
shops gibt und trackt dann den versand für dich automatisch und schickt dir
nachrichten und du kannst nachgucken soweit das ganze ist aktuell kann er
nur dhl dafür kann er dhl relativ gut der dhl versand sieht dann ungefähr so
aus als die unterschiedlichen stationen anzeigen lassen und kriegst auch hier die
nachricht drüber ist gerade unterwegs es wird gerade transportiert es ist im
auto wird an dich wird an dich gerade zugestellt oder es ist fertig
also logischerweise wenn ihr deren api dafür ja aber deren api ist kacke
hier da muss man sie als fau für pasen bei dpd dhl hat eine schöne api eine
ziemlich gute 0815 da ist ein api an der nix großartig raussticht ups hat
glaube ich noch eine xml soap api das haben wir noch nicht ausprobiert
hermes hat nur eine inoffizielle jason api die wir verwenden werden
und was ganz eklig wird mit amazon pasen weil amazon hat gar keine api stützstellen
für versand da müssen wir die webseite pasen was natürlich ein bisschen
fehleranfällig ist aber es gibt halt nichts anderes
ist das der echte aber sowas von java das ist kein java aber sieht ja war
ähnlich das liet pepega das playlist
nützlich für leute in massenbestellen ja vor allem also warum ich das ganze
gemacht habe ist ich hätte gerne auf meinem heim automatisierung dashboard
halten übersicht wie es so mit pakete aussieht und ohne dass ich jedes mal
selbst tracken muss wenn ich was bestellt habe es gibt es gibt paket
tracker wie sand am mer wo du manuell die codes einfügen willst aber ich will
die kauts nicht manuell einfügen ich will dass er die sich automatisch aus
den emails rausholt weil jeder shop jeder mir fällt keine gegen beispiel ein
verschickt an die adresse wo du dich registriert hast eine versand
bestätigung und in der versand bestätigung steht eigentlich so gut wie
immer drinnen der der der anbieter und die sendenummer das heißt wir
scannen einfach die emails durch nach sachen wie hermes dhl ups und nach einem
regex der nach der jeweiligen sendenummer aussieht und dann gucken wir
online beim jeweiligen dienst nach gibt es diese sendenummer und wenn es die
sendenummer gibt flüge was ein
ich bin 35 seit sechs tagen
nach den 42 vielleicht doch 96 69
ja da gewachsen
also ich prokramiere seit ungefähr so 2002 rum wir haben uns das der letzen
zwei überlegt aber ich verdiene also ich verdiene damit kein geld also ich
prokramiert zwar auf der arbeit auch aber ich bin kein hauptberuf der
software entwickler bin im defops bereich wenn sich genau interessiert ich
habe es mal versucht zu erklären muss einfach mal ausrufe zeichen ausruf
zeichnen beruf machen habe ich versucht zu erklären weil ich so treibe
so also leute das schiebe ich mal auf mit dem richtigen sendestatus das mache
ich mal auf stream weil wie gesagt es will keiner mich mich jetzt eine halbe
stunde noch sehen wie ich hier status sachen aus der dpd tabelle copy paste
wir machen jetzt die letzte stunde noch was viel interessanteres nämlich wir
haben wir hier die city als text und die city als text können wir das mit das
mal werken wir mal die ausgabe hier wobei ich habe die ausgabe hier schon drin
stehen und die city als text können wir jetzt reverse look ab zu längern grad
und breiten grad und die lenkrad und breiten grad können wir dann im web
interface auf einer karte darstellen lassen
wir wollen sehen wie du das pdf passt und dann in zwitsch block generiert das
wäre das wäre wirklich das wäre super next level
big brain da müssen ein paar leute subscriben für dass man plane dick
genug wird dass ich das hinkrieg so wir können uns ja mal den ganzen den
ganzen blödsinn hier sparen wir suchen jetzt einfach mal mal
habe ich noch nie gehört weiß nicht wo das liegt wir gucken mal bei google maps
wo das liegt
mal
könnte sehr groß zu sein
huge huge stadt hier
da geht doch so klein ist das gar nicht wo liegt das
nordrhein-westfalen
und wie viele einwohner 7 oder 80.000 das ist gar nicht so klein
warum manuell der csv passen gibt doch eine million passer weil ich glaube für ich
weil wir müssen den pass auch sagen was wir passen wollen und ich glaube für das
bisschen was wir hier machen ist es deutlich einfacher um hier unsere fünf
einträge raus zu holen das mal kurz von hand zu splitten als wir uns noch anzusehen
wie man es jetzt passen zsv library bedient wie man da sachen rauskriegt ich
glaube das ist auch nicht viel kürzer es könnte ein bisschen robuster sein aber
da muss man es einfach mal auf dpd verlassen ok wir machen das jetzt mal
mit dem geo abfrage dazu kommentieren wir mal den ganzen krempel aus den ich
hier habe den brauche erst mal nicht wir machen es mal eine abfrage dass wir also
das problem ist ja nur auf das zu erklären ich will quasi sowas hier
anzeigen lassen ungefähr auf auf meinem versand tracker also nicht dass wenn du
das hier aufklappst und dann drüber gehst will ich dass deine karte anzeigt
wo das paket gerade ist also zumindest wenn der versanddienst quasi sowas an
information rausgibt also würde ich gern sowas hier anzeigen lassen im
endeffekt im interface also dass dann hier dass dann hier wenn man hier drauf
geht da kommt halt eine karte oder oder zwischen den einträgen kommt beim
aktiven eintrag eine karte irgendwie sowas dass ich das machen kann muss
sich erst mal die stadt auflösen zu längen grad breiten grad und da kann man
hat sich verschiedene apis für nehmen man könnte google maps für nehmen man
kann da ob ob ob ob streetmaps sowas das weiß ich gar nicht
zumindest ich kenne ein anbieter womit das funktioniert da habe ich vor einer
weile schon gefunden und zwar ist das
das da die habe ich mir irgendwann auf github gefunden die haben quasi eine api
programmiert das open street map durch sucht aber auch ein github projekt kann
man selbst hausen der server ist in java programmiert und die bieten an dass man
das kostenlos verwenden kann allerdings sagen sie können sie können sich
drosseln wenn du zu viele abfragen macht google maps geht nicht google maps
geht nicht google maps muss den api key generieren
api key ist mit anwendung spezifisch und hat maximal 2000 aufrufe am tag und die
könnten relativ schnell erschöpft sein wenn mehr als fünf leute das programm
verwenden also ich brauche sowas was quasi auf userbasis ist und die
drosseln für pro absender ip das ist viel besser deswegen nehmen wir die api
von denen jetzt
kannst du einfach maps plus url variablen übergeben ich ich habe nichts
was ich was ich den maps übergeben könnte als länge grad und breiten
kann ich meine ich könnte ich könnte quasi diese diese suche api von google
maps verwenden da muss ich erstens google maps verwenden und da muss ich
dann irgendwie google maps i frame oder sowas einbinden bei mir weiß ich ob das
ob das so schön ist
zumindest hier drüber kriegen wir relativ easy raus
außerdem will ich google maps gar nicht verwenden
ja ja doch sebaro aber ich kann ja daran nichts aber ich weiß nicht ob das geht
ehrlich gesagt aber ich kann an google maps nichts
customisern also ist das einzige was ich machen könnte ist ein frame einbinden
mit der offiziellen google maps suche für frankfurt wo man halt rauskommt ich
kann nichts customisern also wieder zum level noch scroll geschichten noch kann
ich auf die map was malen lassen zum beispiel dass dann ein punkt angezeigt
wird oder sowas kann nichts einstellen sobald ich das sobald ich das machen
will sobald ich das machen will brauche ich den api key für google maps
also da ist das auf jeden fall die schönere variante dann nehme ich dem ich
irgendwie keine ahnung lieflet mit mit open street map und kann auf der map
machen was ich will außerdem ist mal ganz interessant rauszukriegen wie das
wie das funktioniert
was auch kurz licht anmachen ist
so lichte 2019
ups ich kann ich einblenden
also
stimmte ttp davor machen und jetzt wieder nicht ok query mir das ganze mal
für berlin gucken wir mal ob es an sich funktioniert kleint
gert string mal gucken ob das jetzt klappt ops soll ich das auch komplett
angeben ja da findet jetzt alles mögliche raus
sehr schön übergeben wir jetzt mal als parameter mal weil mal suchen wir
natürlich können wir das jetzt hier an der stelle nicht direkt übergeben das
funktioniert nicht weil das sind lehrzeichen drin das heißt wir müssen
den kram erst mal url encoden dass es funktioniert
aber kann man vielleicht noch die sprache
wenn ich verkehrt mal wollen wir jetzt url encoden da gab es url encode da gab
es irgendeine klasse
macht das entkommen nicht automatisch muss hier den string den er abruft
selbst zusammenbauen da gab es eine fertige klasse ich habe url encode
weiß bloß gar nicht mehr wie es heißt hat ttp utili genau hat ttp
liti url encode geo url plus plus wo ist es mal
moment muss ich auf die url reinschreiben einfach nur einfach nur mal
muss da reinschreiben encoded so und dann hängen wir das jetzt mal
hintereinander
und jetzt sollten wir die infos zum mal kriegen wo ich weiß nicht wo das ding
ist morgen feiern was morgen ist feiertag aber nicht in hessen
damals doch schon
koordinaten
muss ich mal hier unter linux mir mal kurz angucken das muss man ziemlich
das muss man mit karl mit karl machen und uns ordentlich ordentlich ausgeben
lassen
url encode online auch der url encoder
ja da so encode man das
und das ganze jetzt nach jq palmen dass es ordentlich ausschaut ok also das
kriegen wir hier als antwort da haben wir drin features geometry
koordinates type point type feature das ist geo jason deutschland country
place
ach so dann ist in hessen bei uns morgen kein feiertag
die drei beste also im prinzip wollen wir hier
und sie wollen wir hier das da raus
parsorn features also was müssen wir uns raus passen features und daran oder das
wird wieder ekliger ok also probieren wir das mal aus was
wir jetzt da rausholen features
was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht also ich habe so gar nicht jason gepaßt
j objekt pass und jetzt gucken wir mal features ok das funktioniert als das
innere array dann ich habe keine schmerzen mit dass wir das arbeiten muss ok
dann filtern wir das ganze mal type property
ich will jetzt quasi das element das erste element was was country deutschland
ist was ist denn das dann value property type type keine ahnung
also geht auch in sack
nach was muss ich denn gucken jetzt ich will doch da quasi das nächste
für den nächsten key der der country heißt
der nächste key der country heißt wie kriege ich das heraus key was ist das denn hier
bei jason.net wie backst du eigentlich nie da nie würde ich nicht sagen
wir haben heute schon mal gebugt was könnte das denn sein
das können wir tatsächlich machen
das ist eigentlich keine schlechte idee
also was haben wir da drin
na gut das ist das root element das bringt uns jetzt ja nix
aber wir können mal gucken wie es sich typen objekt
typ
ja
und zwar der first
type feature collection
ich müsste doch jetzt eigentlich properties hier rausholen können
das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren
also ja klar ich dachte er meckert an sich properties und dann will ich nach
nach country gucken
gleich gleich
das ist nicht schön ich muss mal gleich gucken und gucken ob es den geo jason parser gibt
das erste und gucken ob das funktioniert hat ja das muss ein bisschen fehler toleranter
gestalten was machst du da gerade versuche ich wenn ich eine stadt in deutschland habe
den look abzumachen was die für lenken und breitengrad koordinaten hat dass ich dann
in meinem paket tracker anzeigen kann wo das paket gerade ist
arbeitest du eigentlich genau in frankfurt in viel näher in frankfurt kann man nicht
arbeiten das ist fast am hauptbahnhof
das funktioniert gefällt mir zwar nicht richtig ehrlich gesagt und wir könnten jetzt auch so
was hier machen dann ist es null es ist null oder ist was
ich jetzt halt nicht weiß was passiert wenn er das hier nicht findet
jetzt war schön wenn man das als metode aufrufen könnte weil da können stehen hier davor machen
dass man das machen das geht nicht oder und das geht
das geht
ist aber neu oder gut er klagt immer noch aber aber interessant dass es dass es geht
ist auch weiter so dann das geht
das geht
das ist neu das ist neu das habe ich so noch nie gesehen das ist das ist dort net core
3 review 7 visual studio 2019 vorschauversion und csharp 8 features
ja my life ist so so würde ich das mal interpretieren also was es schon eine weile gibt ist ist quasi
das da was im endeffekt heißt wenn wobei das jetzt blöd das da das da gibt schon eine
weile was im endeffekt heißt wenn das da null ist dann hier nicht abkacken sondern einfach
null zurückgeben insgesamt ich wusste allerdings nicht dass das mit dem indexer funktioniert
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich weiß nicht ob das neu ist das habe ich so noch nie gesehen aber
es ist sehr cool dass es funktioniert also es gefällt mir echt gut naja dann sind wir
ja mehr oder weniger eigentlich haben wir jetzt alles alles zusammen was wir brauchen
da machen wir jetzt hier noch privat irgendwie
da übergeben wir die city dann werfen wir den ganzen temple den ich hier habe mal da
rein und dann die turnen wir was hat jetzt für schmerzen also das darf man nicht return
etwas also ist rotate low
w à delivered
mus Skinner es so was gucken ja ich
Also wir haben es ja schon drinstehen Hardcoded, so und jetzt holen wir uns da einfach hier
Properties, Geo mit simple Geometry, Koordinates holen wir uns raus. Also sprich wenn der
graben nicht, da müssen wir mal gucken, was das schöner machen kann. Wenn der graben ungleich Null ist, echt nicht so hübsch.
Moment, so viele Klammern, so viele Klammern. Wenn das nicht Null ist, boah ist das hässlich.
Wie nennen wir das denn, da kann man dem Digger auch einen gescheiten Namen geben.
Geo City, das war mal so ein Web-Hosting-Portal.
Der Keeper xy ist am Start, nice. Was hab ich nicht gesehen, was hast du geschrieben Christian?
Morgen wird ein interessanter Tag, da entscheidet sich ob wir uns ab Oktober wiedersehen. Ach, das hat er heute gespoilert, jetzt verstehe ich das auch.
Oder hast du dich beworben bei uns im Team heute? Oder hast du dich bei uns im Team beworben? Oder woanders?
Der Alex hat heute gesagt, so nach dem Motto, da kommt vielleicht wieder jemand und das hat sich für mich so angenehm, als wäre das jemand, den man kennt.
Und nachdem du das jetzt geschrieben hast, hab ich gedacht, vielleicht wärst du das jetzt gewesen. Ach, andere Positionen. Also nicht bei uns, also irgendwo.
Gehst du da hin, gehst du zu Dominik? Nee, oder?
Das ist für die Leute jetzt übelst wir, checkt keiner um was es geht. Warum nicht?
Solo. Achso, hab ich.
Er geht zu Chantal. Wahrscheinlich. Ah, jetzt weiß ich es. Du gehst zu den iOS App Entwicklungs Mädels.
Ja, wenn ich mir noch mal aussuchen dürfte, würde ich auch zur iOS Entwicklung gehen.
Ach, Netzwerk. Ah, verstehe. Dann ist der dann sieht es demnächst so aus. Interessant. Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt. Vielleicht bist du ja demnächst wieder am Start.
Da muss man selber gucken.
Der ist auch wieder da.
Egal, das haben wir genug gespoilert. Im Prinzip checkt da keiner um was es hier geht.
Alter, kommen sie zurück. Du wirst einige bekannte Leute finden noch bei uns und auch den ein oder anderen, der schon mal da war und nicht bei uns und mittlerweile bei uns ist.
Aber das kann ich jetzt nicht im Stream erzählen, sonst wäre zu viel geleakt. Aber da bin ich echt mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Kommst du irgendwann wieder auch mal vorbei für Bewerbung oder wird morgen erst quasi festgelegt, ob man überhaupt überlegt dich mal einzuladen?
Das wird mich echt mal interessieren, das ist cool.
Okay, jetzt wollen wir noch eine Sache machen, dann sind wir nämlich fertig.
Ich verzichte jetzt mal auf ordentliche Namen, dass wir fertig werden, weil wir haben nur eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Wenn das hier umgleich Null ist, dann holen wir uns das hier raus. Moment, was holen wir uns da raus? Camp, da muss man nochmal die Ausgaben angucken. Geometry holen wir uns da raus.
Das ist so hässlich, was ich da gerade anprogrammiere. Das holen wir uns da raus.
Aber wir sind schon getrosselt, wir sind glaube ich wieder getrosselt, oder kann das sein? Da kommt keine Antwort, wir haben uns schon wieder getrosselt.
Hier, da, das sind die Koordinaten. Okay, cool. Was ist Längengrad und Breitengrad? Wer kennt sich so geometriemäßig aus?
Ist das Längengrad oder das Breitengrad?
Müsste Long Lad sein, dann habe ich das so geschrieben.
Achso, war Long geht nicht. Oder? Geht das? Weil das wäre ja eigentlich Datentyp. Nee, das geht nicht. Link, Link.
So, das ist jetzt zwar richtig hässlich, das mache ich dann Offstream nochmal hübsch. Aber wir gucken mal, ob der Returnwert jetzt stimmt.
Das ist eigentlich dort net ein eingebauter Typ für Geocoordinate Class. Das geile ist ja an dort net, man hat wirklich mittlerweile jeden Shit eingebaut.
Moment, warum ist das jetzt nicht? Ach nee, ist nicht.
At long? Nee, ich mache lieber Link, weil das wird funktionieren. Okay, das muss ich assignmenten. Haben die da schon was eingebaut?
Anscheinend? Anscheinend nicht.
Na gut.
Okay, da müssen wir das anderweitig zurückgeben. Wir könnten jetzt echt mal dieses neue Feature verwenden, was wir vorhin angesprochen haben.
Dass wir quasi, das ist jetzt ein String gewesen. Was programmierst du gerade? Zeige ich dir gleich, wenn ich mal ausprobiert habe.
Wenn ich jeden Schritt fertig habe. Weil wir haben doch noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Okay, das ist EINODGE, kann man das mal als Double Parson.
Da muss ich was Schöneres überlegen, aber erst mal, dass der Kram fertig wird.
Ach, das ist kein String. Boah, wird das hässlich. Huge ugly gerade. Huge ugly.
Das nächste Mal noch Geo-Jason-Parser. So, und jetzt können wir das mal ausprobieren. Wir können dieses neue doppelte Rückgabewert, also zwei Rückgabewerte Feature mal verwenden.
Double, Platt, Double, Double. So kann man das vielleicht jetzt direkt so machen.
Äh, wie weist man da überhaupt was zu jetzt? Wie weist man da jetzt überhaupt was zu? Muss man halt sagen, irgendwie return und dann hier quasi, ähm.
So. Macht mal mehr Rückgabewerte, nicht mit Outparameter. Hier oben habe ich es ja mit Outparameter gemacht. Ähm. So, ich muss jetzt ja was returnen.
Null, null. Ich will jetzt einfach nochmal ausprobieren, ob es funktioniert. So. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Jetzt bin ich echt gespannt, ob der Krempel tut, den ich hier gebastelt habe.
Ähm, zack. Also wieder einkommentieren. Ähm, UPS ist so. Und jetzt gucken wir hier drinnen. Jetzt gucken wir hier drinnen.
Lookup Coordinates für City.
Platt. So, der sollte das jetzt ausgeben für City. Machen wir anders. Machen wir anders, ähm. Machen wir anders.
Ähm, wir machen, wir brauchen noch ein extra Feld in Shipping Pro-Progress. Das nennen wir dann Double.
So. Das da rein.
Mache ich das immer, warum mache ich da keinen. So, R. So, und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Ich bin ja mal echt gespannt.
Große Kleinschreibung, wurscht. So. Meiner, das funktioniert. Funktioniert. Es geht.
Wir kriegen jetzt unsere Sendeverfolgung inklusive Breitengrad. Wir können jetzt ja mal gucken, ob das auch richtig ist.
Es steht nur bei jeder Stadt dieselben Koordinaten. Stimmt.
Ach, ich glaube, ich weiß, warum. Warte mal.
Kann hier funktionieren. Nochmal. Ja, das sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen besser aus, ne? Also, es geht los hier in 51 7.
Das ist Mal. Da wissen wir jetzt, da wohnt der Eichler. Dann geht es nach Freiburg und dann kommt es an. Das ist doch, das ist doch echt hübsch.
Die Proger Streams sind einfach pock. Ja, vor allem, wenn sie funktionieren. Ganz ehrlich, die Funktion gefällt mir null, wie sie aufgebaut ist zurzeit. Und auch das hier gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht machen wir wirklich eine eigene, eigene Klasse, irgendwie Geo, Geo Koordinates und da da schreiben wir dann rein. Keine Ahnung.
Da kann man es nämlich auch richtig nennen. So, das ist doch besser. Kommt mal eine eigene Klasse dafür.
Wofür ist das Interface als Shipment Tracker? Naja, wenn ich das gibt, der DPD Tracker implementiert ist, der Amazon Tracker, der Hermes Tracker, der DHL Tracker.
Da muss ich quasi in der Klasse, die das im Hintergrund ausführt, nicht alle Tracker namentlich wissen.
Klugscheißen erwünscht. Du kannst klugscheißen so viele willst, ob ich es dann mache. Das ist natürlich wieder was anderes.
Ich glaube, das tauschen wir aus, das gefällt mir. Du, das habe ich auch gedacht. Genau das habe ich beim Erstellen auch gedacht.
Und nachdem ich, nachdem ich daran gedacht habe, kannst du ein Struck machen, habe ich mir in der zweiten Sekunde gedacht, Scheiß drauf.
Genau das. Das war das erste, was ich gedacht habe. Man könnte da auch ein Struck draus machen. Und da habe ich mir direkt danach gedacht, weißt du was, wurscht.
Ja, aber könnte man machen. Könnte man machen. Das ist ja Komplett Value Semantik eigentlich.
Da hat ja nichts mit Kapselung in dem Sinn zu tun. Das ist ja ein logischer Typ, der zusammen gehört. Also da könnte noch so etwas wie Höhe oder so etwas rein machen.
Aber das haben wir. Jaja, du hast recht. Welcher Vorteil hätte dann ein Struck? Na eigentlich, praktisch gesehen eigentlich nur, dass man sich besser fühlt.
Es hat ein paar, unter der Haube ein paar Unterschiede. Zum Beispiel, dass Werte kopiert werden und nicht referenziert werden. Aber also wenn du das als Parameter übergibst.
Aber an sich eigentlich nur, dass man sich besser fühlt. Zu 99% ist das wurscht. Wo es nicht wurscht ist, muss man sagen, sind sobald es um irgendwelche unmanaged Sachen geht.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel mit irgendwelchen CAPs oder so interagierst, dann ist das wichtig, weil in einem Struck kannst du dir sicher sein, dass quasi der Speicher hinterländer so ist.
Also sprich, du hast in einem Struck, hast du zuerst deine Zinden das, wie viele Bytes sind das? Wie viele Bytes sind ein Long überhaupt? 32? Äh, nicht Bytes, äh, Bit? Hier, 8.
Weiß gar nicht, was ein Long ist. Ähm, 23 Bit. Da hast du direkt die 23 Bit hintereinander. Also sobald du mit, ähm, wenn Native Sachen interagierst und die wollen einen Struck haben, da muss das auch ein Struck sein.
Du kannst dann auch noch Layout angeben, wie das aufgebaut ist. Aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich ziemlich wurscht. Der hauptsächliche Unterschied zwischen einer Klasse und einem Struck ist eben, dass du, ähm, also dass im Struck manche Sachen defaultmäßig schon implementiert sind.
Die in einer Klasse, die du selbst implementieren musst. Und wenn du einen Struck als Parameter verwendest, dann werden die Werte kopiert und nicht eine Referenz auf was übergeben, was schon da ist. Aber eigentlich ist es zu 99% egal.
Aber ich finde es schick, dass es funktioniert. Das hier oben muss ich mir nochmal überlegen. Das war jetzt einfach nur so dahin gerotzt, dass es irgendwie funktioniert. Ähm.
Pro96 hat gefragt
Ähm.
Also.
Wenn du.
Dich ein bisschen abkoppeln willst von der eigentlichen Implementierung. Also zum Beispiel. Ich glaube mir ist was gutes eingefallen. Zum Beispiel du brauchst eine Datenbank als Speicher.
Weil du eben keine Ahnung, du willst Adressen speichern, Adressen und und verknüpft mit Namen von Kunden oder von von.
Von Leuten, denen du was schicken willst, irgendwas. Du willst Adressen speichern mit ein bisschen Verknüpfung. Ja, du brauchst eine Datenbank.
So jetzt kannst du entweder sagen, okay. Ich ähm. Ach so. Ach du meinst, was das hier macht. Gut, das macht im Prinzip das Gleiche.
Deswegen erzähle ich das jetzt erstmal fertig. Ähm. Und du kannst das jetzt so machen. Du sagst, okay. Ich nehme eh als Datenbank keine Ahnung.
Postgres oder ich nehme eh als Datenbank SQLite. Ja sag mal du nimmst als Datenbank SQLite. Und machst jetzt einfach dein SQLite Zeug direkt von Hand.
Ähm. Ohne das irgendwie zu abstrahieren. Ohne ein Interface. Zum Beispiel einfach Klasse SQLite Dings reingehauen.
So und später kommst du mal auf die Idee. Ah. Ich würde jetzt doch gerne anstatt SQLite. Würde ich gerne Postgres oder so verwenden.
Da musst du quasi deine ganze. Da kannst du deine SQLite Klasse wegschmeißen. Oder deine SQLite Klasse umstricken zu der Postgres Klasse.
Hättest du dann ein Interface. Hättest du dir ein ordentliches Interface überlegt. Danach die Motto Schreibedaten, Lesedaten, Filterdaten, was auch immer.
Und hättest das implementiert in deiner Klasse. In deiner SQL Klasse. In deiner SQLite Klasse. Da könntest du einfach eine neue Postgres Klasse machen.
Implementierst das Interface wieder. Sodass es sinnvoll implementiert ist mit Postgres. Du kannst die zwei Dinge austauschen.
Also du bist quasi unabhängig davon. Dass es SQLite drunter ist oder Postgres drunter ist. Und das ist im Prinzip hier genau der Fall.
Du hast ein Interface. High Shipment Tracker. Und jede Klasse. Das ist noch nicht ganz, ganz perfekt.
Man müsste hier noch eine Methode definieren. So nach dem Motto. Bin ich auch wirklich dafür zuständig.
Also eine Methode wo ich fragen kann. So nach dem Motto. Ey unterstützt du DHL oder sowas.
Das müsste man noch machen. Zumindest. Es gibt einen DPD Tracker. Es gibt einen DHL Tracker. Es gibt einen Hermes Tracker. Einen Amazon Tracker.
Und es könnte ja auch sein. Dass es demnächst mal einen China Mail Tracker gibt.
Und was mich interessiert ist ja nicht wirklich ob es einen DPD Tracker gibt. Einen China Tracker gibt. Oder ob es vielleicht sogar einen Tracker gibt.
Der China Mail, India Mail und Dings alles in einem kann. Es muss ja nicht pro Anbieter einen Tracker geben.
Das ist mir allerdings im Endeffekt in meiner Klasse. Also in diesem Background Scanner wo ich das verwende. Und gucke ob quasi der Status immer wieder alle paar Minuten den Status abfrage von dem Paket.
Da ist mir das egal. Da krieg ich nämlich nicht explizit die Klasse DPD Tracker oder die Klasse DHL Tracker oder die Klasse China Tracker.
Sondern ich sage ich hätte gerne irgendeine Klasse die dieses Interface hat. Und dann ist es egal ob es der China Tracker ist oder der DPD Tracker.
Also sprich mein Scanner, also mein Background Scanner der guckt was die Pakete für einen Status haben. Der muss gar nicht mal wissen dass es überhaupt DPD gibt. Der weiß einfach nur ich hab hier ein Paket von dem und dem Anbieter.
Und der guckt einfach ok ich habe hier irgendwie 10 verschiedene Registrierte Shipment Tracker. Man fragt da einfach mal alle 10 an. Unterstützt ihr Hermes?
Und dann antwortet halt einer oder keiner. Und der da sagt ja ich unterstütze Hermes. Der wird dann aufgerufen mit Track.
Und dass das die Klasse DPD Tracker heißt oder XYZ Omega Lull ist vollkommen wurscht.
Und das Interface implementiert, ne ne ne. Das hier ist das Interface und hier drinne sagst du was die Klassen die das Interface implementieren oder was die Klassen das Interface anbieten wollen implementieren müssen.
Du kannst auch sowas hier sagen ich möchte zum Beispiel ne was wir theoretisch noch brauchen ist keine Ahnung Support for irgendwas.
Und da übergibst du dann den Name von deinem weißt was ich meine der Name ist jetzt nicht so schön ne. Der willst du dann übergeben zum Beispiel ich hab hier China Mail.
Und der wird dann antworten mit ja ich unterstütze China Mail. Und der DPD Tracker würde natürlich antworten ne ne also ich unterstütze China Mail nicht.
Und wie würdest du nun die Klasse DPD Tracker ansprechen über das Interface. Das kann ich dir zeigen das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel.
Anstatt dass ich hier DPD Tracker nehme. Kann ich es nochmal ausschmeißen noch.
Anstatt ich DPD Tracker nehme was ich hier mache sag ich einfach so.
Und nach dem hier muss ich nie wieder den Namen DPD Tracker verwenden. Sondern T ist jetzt vom Typ I Shipment Tracker.
Und das kann ich überall als Parameter verwenden die dieses Interface haben wollen.
Und wenn ich jetzt mal auf die Idee kommen sollte dass mir der DPD Tracker doch nicht gefällt.
Dann tausche ich den DPD Tracker einfach durch den neuen DPD Tracker aus. Und ich muss in meiner Klasse die es verwendet absolut gar nichts ändern.
Ich glaube das konnte man jetzt halbwegs verstehen oder.
Achso irgendjemand hat gefragt Unterschied zur abstrakten Basis Klasse.
Das ist eigentlich recht subtil weil spätestens mit dem neuen C Sharp also mit der neuesten Version verschwimmen die Unterschiede zwischen Interface und abstrakter Klasse weiter.
Bisher war es so du hast eine abstrakte Klasse genommen wenn du ein bisschen mehr Kontrolle über den jeweiligen Typ haben wolltest.
Oder wenn du Basis Funktionalität einbauen wolltest.
Ja also zum Beispiel du hast irgendwie eine Basis Klasse für ein Request und die hat halt Basis Funktionalität dass die sich schon mal irgendwo anmeldet oder so.
Ja die Anmeldung ist immer gleich die kann man in der Basis Klasse machen und da muss sich dann jemand nicht mehr drum kümmern der da eine extra Klasse von ableitet oder sowas.
Jetzt ist es allerdings so oder wenn du wenn du einen Konstruktor brauchst zum Beispiel ja wenn du wenn du dir wenn du wenn es erforderlich ist dass deine Klasse unbedingt im Konstruktor einen bestimmten irgendwas bestimmtes haben muss.
Dann nimmst du eine abstrakte Basis Klasse weil das über den Interface nicht funktioniert.
Bisher war es auch immer so sobald du Logik also so basic Funktionen bereitstellen wolltest.
Dann musstest du das in der Basis Klasse machen weil in dem Interface kannst du bloß die Signaturen vorgeben also nur wie die nur was da implementiert werden muss.
Und nicht wie allerdings in C-Sharp 8 ist es jetzt so oder kommt das vielleicht noch in C-Sharp 8 ist es jetzt so das wissen wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht viele.
Man darf jetzt Default Implementation in den Interfaces machen. Das ist jetzt neu. Das ist jetzt neu.
Da wird man sich natürlich erstmal fragen warum wozu wozu sollte ich so einen Blödsinn machen.
Also wozu wozu sollte ich eine Default Implementierung in dem Interface machen.
Könnte man sich jetzt ja mal ist eine berechtigte Frage wozu man so einen Blödsinn haben will.
Das ist in einem Fall ist das wirklich sinnvoll und zwar ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch schon mal die Klassen angeguckt habt die in DirectX und Direct3D so drin sind.
Die haben so Sachen dann wie keine Ahnung oder nehmen wir ein anderes Beispiel die haben da sowas wie irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Texture 1, Texture 2, Texture 3, Texture 4 das geht dann geht dann bis keine Ahnung.
Texture 95 oder so und warum gibt es das ganze weil ich weiß dass das nicht bei allen Klassen so ist.
Nur als Beispiel jetzt weil irgendwann hat sich Microsoft überlegt okay wir haben eine Klasse die heißt Texture.
Wir wollen jetzt allerdings mehr Funktionen einbauen.
Wir können aber die Klasse nicht ändern beziehungsweise das Interface nicht ändern.
Weil das Interface verwenden ja jede Menge Leute und wenn wir das Interface jetzt anpassen dann ist jeglicher Code das Interface verwendet kaputt.
Und deswegen hat Microsoft gesagt ah ne dann machen wir Texture 2.
Dann kam das wieder wir wollen was neues einbauen dann machen wir Texture 3 und irgendwann ist man bei Texture 95.
So und dafür ist das ganz gut da kann man nämlich sagen okay man erweitert einfach ein altes Interface um eine neue Methode die man implementieren kann.
Und damit der alte Code nicht kaputt geht der die alte der das Interface schon implementiert macht man einfach eine Default Implementierung rein.
Und somit muss man es nicht mehr implementieren weil es ja schon da ist aber halt Default.
Wahrscheinlich wird die meiste Default Implementierung sein not implemented wenn man treiben könnte.
Das wird wahrscheinlich die Default Implementierung bei den meisten Sachen sein könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ja dafür ist was da also wie oft man das braucht ehrlich gesagt mir fällt jetzt da gar nicht so viel ein wo ich das gebraucht hätte mal.
Ehrlich gesagt fällt mir eigentlich gar kein gar nichts ein wo ich das mal gebraucht hätte.
Weiß nicht vielleicht fällt ja NoobDevTV was ein.
Die Erklärung die er geschrieben hat klingt so als kennt er sich aus vielleicht fällt ihm was ein wo man das mal wo er das mal gebraucht hätte.
Vielleicht fällt euch auch was ein also mir fällt jetzt nichts ein wozu ich das mal gebraucht hätte.
Könntest du das C-Sharp-File Paste binden damit ich mir die gleich nochmal angucke kannst einfach Stream VOD gucken.
Kann ich dir Paste binden wenn du willst.
Du kriegst sogar Sonntags Highlight.
Hier.
Ich will gar nicht sehen was die auf Paste binden so treiben.
Man muss aber immer gucken angemerkt so ich erzähle ja öfters mal was wie das so in der.
Also aber so wie das die reine Lehre sich mal überlegt hat.
Es hat oftmals keinen Sinn nur weil was quasi nach irgendeinem Best Practice was mal irgendeiner ausgerufen hat oder nach irgendwelchen Microsoft Dokus oder nach irgendwelchen Programmier Büchern.
Nur weil das da quasi die sinnvollere Lösung ist ist nicht unbedingt automatisch immer so dass es für euer Projekt das sinnvolle ist.
Also wenn die sag mal so wenn die theoretisch schönere Lösung oder die sauberere Lösung darauf rausläuft dass ihr drei Wochen länger braucht oder in der Praxis nicht viel besser funktioniert.
Da muss man sich das überlegen ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Meistens ist es aber allerdings so dass die sauberere Lösung auch automatisch die kürzere knackige schönere Lösung ist.
Und die Felder meistens auch erst nach einer Weile überlegen einen.
Und dann kam dann sollte man es auch schon nehmen.
Wie soll das jetzt Jule gemerkt haben ganz einfach ins Watt gucken.
Oder oder schnell screenshotten.
So da ist zweiter Jule ich muss ins Bett.
Unser unser DPD Tracker funktioniert nicht so ganz schön an allen Ecken und Enden aber wir haben es heute im Stream tatsächlich mal geschafft was fertig zu machen.
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Ich gehe jetzt instant auf Runde pennen.
Morgen wieder 5 45 aufstehen. Dann ist ja morgen schon Donnerstag. Ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich morgen irgendwelche komischen Gemiete habe wo ich keinen Bock drauf habe.
Oder ob das ein Tag ist wo ich.
Oh ja habe ich.
Ganz viel Spaß.
Da habe ich schon Bock drauf.
Also das Ding ist ja immer so diese diese diese Einladung nennen sich immer Optimierung.
Faktisch wird da in diesen Meetings nichts optimiert.
Da wird allerhöchstens besprochen was man eventuell mal optimieren könnte.
Das ist aber auch das höchste der Gefühle was da besprochen wird.
Aber den den also den ehrlich gesagt den einzigen Tipp den ich habe für langweilige Meetings.
So durfte es jetzt so durfte es jetzt klingt ja ist die Meetings einfach nicht langweilig werden zu lassen indem man mitmacht.
Ich war ich weiß ich habe selbst immer keinen Bock auf solche Sorten Meetings und ich hatte früher mal das Problem.
Ich bin da halb eingepennt bei da hast du da gesessen hast du dich null interessiert.
Das Einfachste was man machen kann ist mitzumachen.
Da muss nichts sinnvolles rauskommen es erwartet bei diesen Meetings meistens noch nicht mal einer dass da wirklich jetzt bahnbrechende neue Sachen rauskommen.
Einfach sein Senf dazu geben.
Was einen meistens daran hindert oder was mich oder was mich was mich früher immer daran gehindert hat ist wenn es in den Meetings um Thema ging.
Wo ich mich nicht so hundertprozentig ausgekannt habe habe ich lieber die Klappe gehalten weil ich gedacht habe wenn ich jetzt was sage und das ist Blödsinn.
Dann nimmt dich ja keiner mehr an so nach dem was du da erzählst die Wahrheit ist aber dass keiner oder kaum einer wirklich Ahnung von dem Zeug hat was in diesen Meetings besprochen wird.
Und noch weniger jemand der Ahnung hat und sich gleichzeitig dafür interessiert und mitmachen will.
Also eigentlich kannst du nur gewinnen dadurch wenn du was sagst.
Das ist dir selbst nicht so langweilig.
Das einzige der einzige Nachteil daran ist dass dann der Veranstalter denkt oh der interessiert sich aber voll für den kann ich zum nächsten Mal wieder einladen.
Das ist der einzige Nachteil davon.
Aber das wirklich also das was bei langweiligen Meetings am besten hilft ist seinen Entfer zu geben.
Dann ist man nämlich ein bisschen dann ist man nämlich einfach ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Also es ist einfach nur zwei Stunden das geht auch wieder glaube ich drei oder vier Stunden morgen.
Ein paar.
Gut Leute.
Es war.